my friends it has been a very
very spicy past couple of days
last night we got word that the biden
family
joe biden's son and his brother are
under federal criminal investigations
now they're trying to pass it off as
though it's just
you know hunter says it's about his
taxes but now we actually have
confirmation
that it actually involves potential
money laundering and elicit
business dealings with china illicit
business dealings that were facilitated
in part by
joe biden who flew his son on air force
two to china to negotiate a private
equity deal
we also had a former family confidant
tony babilinski who said that he
believes the bidens are compromised
the media covered this story up social
media banned the story
when it came out npr said it wasn't news
it was a distraction
and now just about a month after the
election we are being told by politico
it's an explosive political story that
will rock the biden administration
so why did they block us from hearing
about it from knowing about it why did
they lie
i think this is one of the biggest media
scandals in u.s history but we actually
have bigger news than this
20 states have filed amikai
briefings joining or i should say
supporting the defendant states
in the supreme court request for leave
okay so this is i'm not a lawyer but let
me try and break it down texas filed
uh asked permission to the supreme court
to file a lawsuit against four states
for violating the elector's clause of
the constitution texas wants these four
states to appoint their electors
the legislatures to appoint their
electors effectively saying trump wins
if that's what the
legislatures choose so far now 17 other
states
have signed a brief supporting the suit
and i believe four or five actually
filed intervention asking to be listed
as plaintiffs in the case
saying as they have suffered injury as
well and now 20 states on the other side
blue states
as well as two territories are filing a
brief on behalf of the defendants
what do you call it when half the
country lines up against the other half
of the country
saying that i reject you uh your
president and this election
i don't know where all this goes but i
think things are going to get absolutely
insane
we actually have at least one guy in
texas saying it's time for texas
a state representative calling for texas
to
declare its right to secede from the
union we got a bunch more
tulsi gabbard proposing a bill
effectively supporting trump's calls to
get rid of section 230 she says
that we have to these these companies
have to treat people fairly not censor
them so
man we just got we got way too much
facebook is being sued by 48 states i
don't even know how much we're able to
get to
but i must say we have a very very
important guest
we have matt brainard on the show matt
is i guess you're the founder of the
voter integrity project that's correct
do you want to briefly explain just you
know
what it is you you do sure um well i'm a
political consultant which is a dirty
word in this town but
i've i've worked in campaigns all around
the country um over the last i don't
know
20 25 years going back to the mid 90s i
was the director of data and strategy
for trump's campaign in 2016
at least through the primaries and
after the election there were a lot of
questions being raised and i decided to
create the voter integrity project to
try to identify
anomalies uh potential anomalies i
didn't start with any preconceived
notions of what i'd find i thought you
know maybe i'll find nothing and it was
a clean election
maybe i'll find a few things that don't
make a difference or maybe i'll find a
lot
and those findings have uh resulted in
you know
become the basis of court cases become
the basis of uh
legislative hearings um and also brought
a lot of scrutiny to the assist
the election system we have in this
country and how how badly managed it is
across so many different states so um
so far the you know the project's been
doing pretty well but it's about time to
you know it's in the litigation phase
and
and uh i'm just very grateful to all the
donors the folks in my team
uh who helped us put together all this
data and uh what we tried to do is that
if we're gonna find something wasn't
going to be speculation
or theories um or you know
some kind of complex mathematical
formula it was going to be actionable
material and
now that actual material is in the hands
of lawyers and litigators and
perhaps will have an impact on the
outcome there's ongoing litigation in
many states as well as i'm referencing
these you know 20 states versus 20
states or whatever so i'm
there's a lot of things i'm pretty sure
you can't talk about because it could
theoretically compromise something so
but uh is it is it can you can you uh
can you call it evidence i have
submitted
evidence of potentially legal ballots
in six states so and actually uh
incidentally more states
um when we look at uh double voting so
yeah all that's been submitted but you
know i can't get
too deep into it because it is involving
ongoing litigation and uh
but we can speak about generally how the
system works so uh i can say one thing
uh now try to be really careful but
there have been some statements made by
matt on twitter about potentially
illegal ballots
uh evidence and i've reviewed some of
this information
and independently corroborated what
appears to be
backing up claims i'm trying to be vague
because the ongoing litigation but i can
just say
uh based on what i've seen and
independently independently verified i
believe matt is
correct and telling the truth and i
guess we'll see how it plays out in
court so let's
look for all i know there's a lot of
people who are listening and they're
just like get
more specific get juicy you know we
could theoretically just come out and
say like here's everything and publish
everything and then you lose the court
case and i'm sure nobody wants it to
happen and
i think that the judge might be uh the
litigators and this might be upset
because we want to make sure we respect
the court process so that's really
important
that being said we're going to read
about what's going on with this uh the
responses
oh i want to can i jump in yeah of
course i hate to interrupt but no
problem any all the all the questions
that we can't ask
now and answer now i'm more than happy
to answer them
everything in excruciating detail once
the litigation is done
so that's the only it's not that i don't
want to answer it's just it's a delay
right right right well we want i i think
it's about respecting the courts
right whether whether it's for or
against trump i think the judges and the
people who are working this process
some of them might not make good
decisions but i respect the courts and i
think
you know a lot of these judges would
would appreciate the respect of
us not litigating their case in the
court of public opinion but
we're going to talk about it we are uh
also joining us again is luke
caskey because he lives in my parking
lot yes i corroborated
the corroborators as we were finding out
all the information hi
i am the capo behind we are change.org
and yes i live in tim paul's parking lot
thanks for having me on i have a parking
lot yes you do it's actually a big
driveway but
you can fit a trailer in it ian's
hanging out he's got the crystal ball
and the beautiful aurora borealis
painting
gorgeous crushed quartz is that what it
is yeah wow
cool it's a quartz ball yeah they brush
it in a laboratory
that's crazy things would trade their
their entire treasures their treasuries
for things like this in the middle ages
and now we make them in a laboratory for
80 bucks
right on is also producing i'm here in
the corner pushing buttons
so if you haven't already smash that
like button subscribe hit the
notification bell you can find us on
itunes spotify all those great platforms
and give us good reviews to help out the
show and
share the show with your friends if you
think we're doing a good job i think
we're gonna have a
relatively spicy conversations but the
first big story
we're gonna get into it after you smash
that like button check this out
this is the actual document from
supremecourt.gov
they say state of texas plaintiff versus
the commonwealth of pennsylvania state
of georgia state of michigan
and city wisconsin defendants i don't
want to read all of these states i'm
going to read all these states okay
motion for leave to file and brief for
the district of columbia
and the states and territories of
california colorado connecticut
delaware guam hawaii illinois maine
maryland massachusetts minnesota nevada
new jersey new mexico new york north
carolina oregon rhode island vermont
virginia u.s virgin islands washington
have all been are now partying
in opposition to texas and they
basically just say
that you know they have the right to uh
you know they're asserting their right
to
join the defendants i suppose and issue
a statement on their behalf
so i mean that's about it in terms of
the breaking news but we do have the
direct
response from these states this is from
amny
states respond to texas trumpists
supreme court lawsuit
seeking to throw out the results of the
us election for those that aren't
familiar
with what texas is requesting texas said
that these four states that are listed
as the defendants have
violated the elector's clause of the
constitution which states the state
legislatures have the ultimate authority
in who decides you know the elections
and who the electors are
but in these states the courts overruled
in certain circumstances or
the governors implemented new rules
without permission or confirmation from
the legislatures
therefore and for a variety of other
reasons i'm not going to get into the
full breakdown of their lawsuit is
they're basically saying texas
and all 17 states now either supporting
or asking to intervene to join
are saying that the state legislatures
should be the ones who choose the
electors
their republican state legislatures they
would very likely vote for trump or
perhaps they would abstain and if they
did
joe biden would not reach 270 electoral
votes we would likely move to a
contingent election based on house
delegations in which
donald trump would win of course if they
chose their electors
trump would win so these other states
are basically saying no and now we have
half the country lining up against the
other half
arguing about who the next president is
supposed to be i wonder how that will
play out
but the four states had to issue their
response by today and they did
and so am new york says four u.s states
that president donald trump
lost in the november third election on
thursday began to file court papers
opposing a long-shot republican-backed
lawsuit filed by trump supporting texas
attorney general ken paxton
in the lone star state's name at the
supreme court seeking to undo
president-elect joe biden's victory i
like how they say it's just in texas's
name it's like not actually texas doing
it
officials from georgia maine i'm sorry
georgia michigan pennsylvania wisconsin
already have called the lawsuit which
aims to throw out the results
a reckless attack on democracy the
supreme court gave the four states a 3
p.m est deadline to file court papers
pennsylvania was the first to file with
the state's democratic attorney general
josh shapiro saying
that the texas lawsuit was adding a
cacophony of bogus false claims about
the election quote
what texas is doing in this proceeding
is to ask this court to reconsider a
massive baseless claims
about problems with the election that
have already been considered and
rejected
by this court and other courts the
lawsuit is supported by trump and 17
other states the republican president
has falsely claimed he won reelection
and has made baseless allegations of
widespread voting fraud state election
officials have said they found
no evidence of such fraud i want to stop
there can i ask you about that
about the lawsuit well just about the
state election officials saying they've
found no evidence of such fraud is there
anything you can comment in that regard
because i don't want to
i'm not going to comment i'm going to
question i'm going to questions what did
they do to
find it what efforts did they make to
discover it because
if i close my eyes and and you come here
and take my drink
and i don't see you do it i don't have
any evidence you took it because i
closed my eyes right if i'm sitting
there drinking that red bull yeah
but so well that's my question is that
what evidence can they
provide that they applied scrutiny to
what happened
and of course you didn't find anything
if you didn't look for it
it's you know it's not it's rarely is it
so blatant it takes a lot of effort and
you know our own little independent
project we crowdfunded
about six more than now but uh 580
thousand dollars to sort of fund it on
our own
using very you know tools that were
available to us
why wasn't the state doing this what
what scrutiny did they apply
to i'm actually shocked by a lot of
these court cases
where you know i think in nevada the
trump campaign
presented actual evidence and the court
just said get out of my courtroom they
didn't care
they didn't even look at what was given
to them and then what we end up seeing
is officials say
there was no evidence there was there
was none i liken it to
you know if i said hey you guys want to
play hide and seek and then everyone
goes and hides and then i'd like you
guys one
just like literally right away well i
couldn't find you it's like you didn't
even get out of your chair oh well you
know i couldn't find you
to what to what degree am i obligated i
don't know if you saw uh have you been
following the lawsuits at all
from the trump campaign well i've been
involved with some of them so
right right right so of course but uh
the ones not involving
you know your project or whatever one of
the things that i just want to say and
feel free to comment on what you can or
can't you know just ignore
but in in pennsylvania a judge ruled
that the election law in pennsylvania
says there has to be observers
and trump's campaign said the observers
weren't allowed near the ballots so how
are they observing
and the judge goes well i don't know the
law doesn't specify distance so as long
as they're in the building
it's good which is clearly not good
faith or to the spirit of the law is
supposed to do
and that's the gist of what we've been
seeing across the board so this whole
thing is freaking me out to be honest
now now that we're seeing all of these
states line up it doesn't matter
like you know i'm gonna put it this way
these 20 states and two territories
that are saying oh we reject this it's
it's you know these four states have
said
it's an attack on democracy it doesn't
even matter what their opinion on this
is
because they're not going to change the
minds of 18 other states
we're at a point now where 18 states
have said definitively biden should not
be president i mean well i should say
effectively said might not be president
or the elector the constitution has been
violated texas's lawsuit
says either the constitution matters or
it's just a parchment sitting in the
national archives
that's a powerful statement with 17
states signing on in support of it some
actually asking to intervene to be
listed as as
plaintiffs uh in the case in which case
if the supreme court refuses to hear
this then
these 17 states have already asserted
that would that would be a declaration
the constitution is meaningless
and these other states could effectively
say the same thing
if the supreme court can say no to this
election you know
uh joe biden isn't going to be president
because we've ruled it
they'll they'll argue it's the exact
same thing so that's why i just look at
this and i'm like you know
ultimately it doesn't matter what this
one judge said people
have been lining up and they know
they're right on both sides they both
say they're right
i happen to think one side is more right
than other obviously we all have our
biases
but everyone thinks they're right right
and you know
let's there are many causes to this but
one i think the major contributor
to all of this is how badly the states
manage
elections we've been very lucky because
historically many uh elections are won
by somebody by a pretty good size margin
and what happens is when there's a good
enough margin the mismanagement
is covered up right it's concealed but
when the margins are close
sometimes that mismanagement and
mismanagement comes in other
you know variety of things it could be
uh creating clerical errors or
preventing potential fraud so for
example there's really very little
authentication done on mail and battles
essentially zero
and very little authentication done on
election day bouts we had
a james o'keefe show up in dc and take
the attorney general's ballot they gave
it to him said hey i'm the attorney
they used his name was at this this time
around her oh it's a couple cycles back
but
you gotta remember that yeah yeah so the
election system
has right or wrong created a space for
suspicion
to burn like a wildfire because it's so
badly managed and here's something to
think about right
potholes on the highway right we're kind
of used to the government maybe not
doing the best job of that
your mail getting lost we're we're kind
of a
you know okay yeah postal service this
is always a joke it's a punch line right
or um let's say your medicare not paying
a bill that it should pay
and you have to fight with them we're
all used to that but one thing that i
don't think a democracy can survive
is that kind of uh government
those kinds of bad uh management
within the election system or with that
kind of incompetence in the election
system because that's the thing that
allows us to potentially fix all these
other problems so we're okay with maybe
the potholes don't get fixed or
or maybe you know they mismanage a
hurricane which is horrific right
but the means we have to fix those
problems is the election system so but
if that is
deemed broken well then you're stuck
then you can't fix any problem beyond it
i always say if you want someone to be
an anarchist put him at the dmv for a
week
and we saw that with the the counting
that that was going on
that showed just wait states can't even
count their
argument breaks there's wealth so so
let's address that right
the left has said uh the democrats the
reason why it took longer to count votes
after election day was because when
people go and vote in person
there they walk in and then someone asks
them their name they're given their
ballot or they go to the machine and
they type in things and they press enter
all that's done right away when absentee
vote is being counted they grab the
envelope they look at it they open it
it takes longer to go through the
envelope than it is to have a person
walk and vote and walk out
so the argument is when a person walks
in and votes and walks out it's already
in the tabulation machine
when they're going through absentee
belts doing signature verification it
takes
a bit longer to tabulate that vote and
thus it took a lot longer
but what doesn't make sense in my
opinion is then why they dumped all of
these
batches you know at you know really
early in the morning
at once and it still took more than one
day to do all of this and these these
batches came in so
if you look at i think like november 4th
at like one in the morning there were
massive spikes
well if they were counting on election
day where people came in
and they didn't start counting the
ballots until election day why do we
have
you know not the bouts being entered in
at a certain point i guess the argument
is they were barred from doing it
i still don't think it makes sense as to
how in some circumstances
trump received a tiny fraction of of
these these these mail and ballot dumps
that's that's the big question that i
think needs to be answered
right and there's also a legal argument
in pennsylvania before the election
asking the government to count the votes
that were mailed in early
the the government of pennsylvania
argued against that and
republicans yeah yeah and then when we
look at florida i think florida is the
most interesting case because we saw
that
they were caught with their pants down
in 2000 and then they kind of updated
their voting system and
they had the votes in right away all
these other states we don't have one
universal standard
or one kind of voting machine or one
kind of system to count the votes and i
think that's also something to really
think about here
i i hear you but each state runs their
own election exactly and i i can respect
that but what i can't respect is
let me let basically base off what you
just said let me give people an analogy
would you be willing to get on an
airplane if if airlines had a one
percent failure rate
one percent i think the answer answer
was a resounding
no well there would be no airline
industry in that scenario because they'd
be paying out lawsuits every day
well because no one would fly right i
mean so
new york times reported in 2012 that the
failure rate of mail-in and absentee
voting is between one and two percent
if i told you there's a one percent
chance that if you mailed in your vote
it would not count
well i think a lot of people probably
don't know whatever i don't care but
that's a pretty
pretty bold bet to make to not having
your voice heard in your election
so when i when i saw that we there was
this and this is a big part of the
lawsuit going
uh going forward with um mike kelly and
sean parnell
pertaining to the constitutionality of
mainland voting in pennsylvania
there's a few weird things but when i
saw that all of these changes have been
implemented a year in advance before
covered and during kova to have mass
mail in voting
i mean we saw in paterson new jersey a
whole election was thrown out
a judge actually ordered a new election
in paterson new jersey because they
found bundles of mail-in votes
from a town over we now have a
whistleblower
who's come out and said they drove a
truckload of ballots from new york to
pennsylvania
um i i don't know if that's true you
know witness testimony is is
often unreliable but it is still
evidence admitted in court
so it needs to be considered it needs to
be investigated we need to
look into these things and not just
ignore them and so i i guess i throw it
back to what you said earlier how hard
have any of these people actually looked
into any of the stuff
right right and you know i actually can
talk about one court case i actually
won a court case in federal court
earlier this year
over mismanagement of an election
because you know a lot of these states
are doing things they haven't done
before florida
the mail and ballot situation they have
that they have that down
they know they've got it down um the
voters have it down they know their role
but a lot of these states that because
of um
the pandemic and other reasons are
shifting to things they've never done
before
idaho uh decided they were going to do
an all mailing ballot
um uh primary right and i had a
candidate there was on the ground
and uh the absentee ballot request
deadline was coming up and secretary of
state was going out
you know telling everybody just go to
the website until
5 pm on the deadline day and and go
ahead and request your absolute ballot
well we were we were identifying our
supporters many of whom didn't know
that and telling them yeah go to the
website and request well
website crashed completely went down now
rather than owning the problem
right the secretary of state fought us
in court we had to sue them in federal
court
to get them to extend that deadline and
i
you know something to keep in mind is
that this system that we're
being critical of the people who are
responsible have the
the ability to change it who are running
things they were elected by the system
they're in control of it and it's it was
what put them in power so
uh getting them to realize that there's
serious problems with it they're like
well it put me here
i got this job i've got this power why
would i want to change it
i think we see that with republicans and
democrats
right so it's you look at areas that are
you know deep blue or deep red
and we i had a guy on the show his name
was billy prempe he's a republican
running in north jersey
and i think patterson is is part of the
district he was running in and he he was
i i don't want to put words in his mouth
i might i i want to make sure i'm being
careful here but my understanding of the
conversation was he was not getting any
support from the republican party
because they were like it's too
expensive to even bother with a deep
blue district
and i'm like well if you have an area
that's you know d
plus 20 in an area that's r plus 20 and
you don't even
bother trying to talk to people and talk
about what is important for this country
then they will never change but i think
the real the real issue is that
the republicans are like no no we don't
mess with their safe spaces and they
don't mess with ours so i get guaranteed
re-election and so do they and we kind
of just chill out on it it's not a
battleground area
why push it and that's my opinion on it
there's some evidence that i think it's
more of a vicious cycle
and that the district looks like no
republican win because it's d
plus 20. so no good republican run so
the only republicans that run
are bad candidates who ended up losing
by 20 points that's why it's
d plus 20. right you know going back in
history though i think
um do you remember a guy named howard
dean vaguely yes
well after he lost his presidential race
he took over the dnc
uh that was a while ago yeah well this
it but the i think that the
what i'm getting at is is still true is
he the e-haw guy yeah he is
about to make that thing he was a
terrible presidential candidate but a
fantastic
dnc chair and he did something novel he
says we're gonna have a 50-state plan
we're not letting south carolina go
we're not letting alabama go we're going
to invest resources in all 50 states
and just a few years after that they
retook congress winning seats and made
these states so
parties can neglect areas saying oh we
don't stand a chance there at their own
peril but
before you were able to win that
district you had a guy that got a 30 of
the vote and then
another guy got 40 and 45 and then 50
and then you built something up there
so um i agree with you that's minding
your own territory there's certainly
something that but also it's just this
vicious cycle of ignoring areas that you
don't think can win well it
it it's self-fulfilling yeah when you
look at the gerrymandering and some of
the dirty tricks and politics that they
especially played on individuals like
cynthia mckinney
uh it was just absolutely incredible to
see just the maneuvering the
repositioning the redistricting that
happened
in order to get a favorable outcome even
towards their democratic allies that
didn't play along with their kind of
party
party establishment line and i remember
during this cycle seeing what happened
in iowa
during the democratic primaries and
thinking oh boy we are
in trouble because if you remember we
didn't have a result
uh from that as well and that was a
democratic primary and i'm like wait
they can't even get this right new york
was jammed up too
yeah i can actually give you one good
argument for gerrymandering though
so uh often what people will show when
they're arguing against gerrymandering
is you'll have you know like it's like a
grid of blocks and they'll be like blue
and red
and they'll say you know it's 40 percent
red and 60 percent blue
and here's how they gerrymander it to
make sure you get more republican
representation than democrat
however my response that is if 40
of your state is republican and you do
districts just by blocks
then you will get zero representation
for one for forty percent of this of the
you will that's going to
breed chaos yeah four percent of the
people feeling like they're not being
represented
so there there there is a good reason
for gerrymandering i just think
the actual outcome of gerrymandering is
exploitation to manipulate and guarantee
seats and jobs
well you know it's funny you bring this
up because i actually am a professional
gerrymanderer
i work for the nation's career everyone
hates you
for all kinds of reasons um but i i
worked for the nation's premier
districting firm
uh for about 12 years and i helped with
drawing lines in the city of chicago
illinois rhode island
arizona all these different places
congressional down to city
and i'll be honest with you um i don't
think there's a fair way to draw a line
because if you don't
some people let's say you draw the line
on party right okay well that's
that gives you a favorable outcome to
party but what's the alternative drawing
it based on geography
well that gives a favorable outcome to
you know certain geographies right
so there's there's really no way
there's no way to draw the lines that
somebody can't say well that's not fair
because this person's at a disadvantage
and you can make the case too is that if
you draw a district that gets
you pack all your democrats in the state
into one district it's 90 percent
democrat
and all the republicans around are
winning by 55 percent right here's the
thing though
in that democrat district the democrat
won by 90 percent of the vote
90 of the people there are had their
choice
selected and sent to congress whereas in
the republican districts only 40 percent
of the people
55 percent of people 51 had their choice
so
you know that 90 democrat district has
well those people
had their choice you know they're
happier the district has a higher level
of happiness because
most of them got their choice for
congress the reason i'm very familiar
with it is because dennis kucinich and
cynthia mckinney bring this up as an
example to how they were kicked out of
congress
when they had a big popular support they
were big kind of populist figures
and according to them it was
gerrymandering it was this kind of
redistricting that got him out of office
and it was used by the democratic
establishment
so they wouldn't be in power well
remember the people who drew those lines
were also elected
by the citizens of those states they
were drawn by state legislators elected
by people and the thing is
gerrymandering redistricting whatever
you want to call it it's like the most
vicious political fights you will ever
see and the reason they get so vicious
is because the press doesn't pay any
attention to it and the public doesn't
care
so the long knifes come out no one's
afraid to slit somebody's throat worse
you know figuratively figuratively of
course of course
of course whereas in the more public
battles over policy issues you know
the press pays attention to people kind
of care but it's it's one of the most
vicious
dirty and underhanded battles that
you'll ever see if you
if you see it at all well they do
something like take a ten zones
and then pack all 98 percent of the
republicans into one zone
and then so there's nine of the zones
win democrat and then one zone is
republican or vice versa and then so the
democrats have massive power because
they stuck all the republicans into one
zone
it happens both ways and you know
there's a sort of a you've got the
party thing too but you've got another
thing that kind of interferes with that
which is the race
factor and that the courts think that
there should be minority majority
districts
and we have energy majority districts
that also that inherently
forces you to pack because of the way
they tend to vote
democrats and it can't just be 50
there's
laws jingles supreme court decision you
basically have to draw a district at
least 65 percent minority
so that's basically a 65 democrat pac
district so you often have is that
and this has happened before the
republicans in the state legislature
and the black democrats get together and
cut out the other democrats because
the republicans are happy to give create
plenty of black majority districts for
them to get reelected and have more
colleagues the republicans get all the
other districts sort of
they work together so it's a complicated
process
weird system yep what would you consider
gerrymandering to be like corrupt or bad
like
inherently or is it just the
exploitation of it
look i i think it's a little bit
overstated the impact it has i'll give
you a simple example
in 1990 when the draw lines were being
drawn after the last census
republicans had complete control over
drawing exactly four districts
democrats had complete control over
drawing i don't know two
this is basically you have the both
legislations in the governor you have
complete control you can draw lines
however you want
so republicans had control of four
districts democrats had control of
it's like 200 or so and a couple of
others were split up despite that
two years later the republicans kept
captured their first
uh congressional majority in like 50
years or so that was in the 90s right
but that those reliance were drawn only
so what i'm getting at is that um it it
has an impact
but it's not completely dominant and
then back in 2000
republicans were dominant they had
control over drawing many lines on their
own yet
a few cycles later despite that
democrats took control of congress in
2006
so um it has an impact
but i think sometimes it's a little bit
overstated and people
and i really don't know what the
alternative is i mean people want to do
a parliamentary system but i think that
actually will that would be even worse
because then you're not
the representative isn't tied to a
geography which i think is most
forget party forget race for you are
from this town you represent this town
and that i think that's what's most
important that we maintain
so let's uh let's talk about the water
tag voter integrity project
do you want to just explain what it is
and what you
what you did sure so in the a couple
days after the election
i you know had some ideas about ways to
detect
um potentially illegal ballots i shared
the idea
um with a few people privately but it
really no one really took me up on and i
didn't want to even
i initially did not plan to have
anything to do with it was just hey
here's some methods you could use to
potentially detect
um illegal ballots and i tweeted about
it
and at the time i had like 200 twitter
followers or something
and somebody who followed me who had a
little bit of influence
retweeted it and then somebody else
retweeted it and then it sort of
exploded
and people were saying well you should
set up a gofundme because in the initial
tweet i said
well it's probably going to cost about
100k for just the data to do this
and i said okay fine i set up a gofundme
and uh we raised 220k wow and
within 24 hours and then gofundme shut
the thing down and refunded everybody
their money
whoa they lied to a journalist about why
they shut us down they and i have the
record of this and we may
have more legal matters to discuss can
you tell us why oh sure yeah what they
said was that um
that we were spreading misinformation we
didn't spread
all we said was like here's some here's
some tests we want to run
and this is what we're going to do with
the money they told a reporter they'd
shut us down for spreading this
information
um so within a few you know i did my
homework we found another
crowdfunding site called give send go i
can't recommend these guys
enough their rates are very fair
i knew they weren't going to throw us
off and in fact they don't make money
directly on it it's just that when you
make a contribution to us they ask you
for hey do you want to help us out too
and a lot of people do
so we were able to raise much more at
when we hit 580
000 whoa i said i said that look
um we've raised enough money to cover
what i think are the expense of this
project
we're not asking for any more money um
any money that's left over after we're
done will be returned to donors if they
like it
anybody that's left over after that will
go to a c3
that um a nonprofit a non-profit that's
basically about voter registration
fighting potential voter fraud
and in all those cases no matter where
it goes i'm not personally going to take
a penny of it
um and so but despite that people have
continued to contribute we're all we're
almost a hundred thousand beyond where i
said okay
we have the money to cover this so
you're
looking at uh doing some tests on
whether or not
ballots may be illegal is that correct
that's how we started i built a team of
of
a couple of people who are have similar
backgrounds to my own
um and we started obtaining raw voter
data from states we started
can you explain that because that was
crazy to me that you can get people's
information on how they voted or not how
they voted but that they voted
oh well you can get indications about
how they voted this is yeah
it's too bad i don't have a screen or
something because i can just pop it open
i
i know everything that anybody would
want to know about every voter in this
country
that's at my fingertips it's kind of
creepy that's life and you know it's
also it's kind of unique to the united
states because i've talked about doing
i've talked to
doing political consulting in other
countries it's kind of difficult because
they're very strong privacy laws in
europe et cetera but in the u.s
i know everything a campaign want to
know so in terms of voter contact or
voter analysis it's
it's it's all there and um in this case
we were able to attain you know
voter lists from the state states often
release chase files and that means that
every day for like two months leading up
to the election they released a list of
all the people who
uh requested ballots uh or return
ballots
who showed up to vote early and that's
helpful for campaigns because
if you have like these hundred thousand
people you're trying to reach and turn
out to vote
if the state says okay this person just
voted you can take them off their list
so you're no longer wasting money on
doors phones
mail any and social anything else to
target them because you can take them
off your list and focus on the remaining
ones it's called
strike listing so all this is very
useful for that but in this case we
obtained that data to use it to try to
attack detect
potential problems and we used other
government databases to help validate
our methods and to
compile our evidence can you tell us
some of these tests what were you
proposing to do
during this original gofundme and this
new kind of fundraiser
well initially we're going to do some
traditional
analysis looking at double voters
looking at people who no longer
had residency looking for potential uh
dead voters
um uh and and as we got into it
we started to discover other things
other methods that we had not thought of
but then said oh that's something we
should look into
because this is this is unprecedented
you know this has not really been done
before
where uh you go in depth after an
election because usually after an
election the margin is such that there's
no doubt
and nobody's got any money left and
everyone you know honestly it's
thanksgiving
it's christmas time we are unique
because we have this long period between
the election and when the person takes
office now in the uk
day after election they're in and out of
downing street it's like wow that
whereas yeah it's immediate that sounds
terrible
well i think i think it's already bad
enough that we have a couple months
because if you really wanted to do any
kind of hard investigation we don't have
the time to do it
and we have months right well rarely
have we had the need
i think and again it goes back to what i
say is that the fundamental problem
behind a lot of this is that
the elect you know there you remember
florida
uh 2000 right nightmare a couple hundred
votes nightmare
the thing is i don't think there's any
state that would not be a nightmare
if if the election came down to a couple
thousand votes
and it was very pivotal there's not a
state i think that would
escape finding all kinds of flaws it's
just those states tend to they're saved
by the victor winning by enough of a
margin that it's like
yes you know no ma the errors and
potential if it existed fraud can't
overcome that margin but here we are
in some of the lawsuits trump presented
the judges have said the amount of
ballots you're questioning would not be
enough to change the outcome therefore
dismissed
i think that's kind of silly because you
add up 10 lawsuits targeting specific
different things
maybe but that's actually been some of
the results yeah that's more a question
for the lawyers in terms
because i've seen cases where actually
the um
the the number of questionable ballots
did not have to surpass the margin it
just had to demonstrate some kind of
pattern
and that was enough to get get it thrown
out i think that was the case in miami
when a judge ruled there was voter fraud
down there and threw out a mayor's
election
can you elaborate any more on what the
learned higher education project has
done so far or
is that off limits you know i think my
twitter feed's covered extensively but
we found all kinds of
uh uh indications of illegal ballots and
other anomalies who presented them on
youtube it's pretty uh i mean we
essentially ran about 38 tests across
six different states
and we put our results out there
publicly um just at this point you know
for the next
short period of time i think it's i've
been encouraged
you know to respect the the litigation
and
i think we don't want to you know with
respect to the judges involved in this
case
i think they would appreciate it if we
weren't you know litigating in public
right but once that's done well you know
we'll crack that laptop up put a
projector up and start
start showing stuff well yeah
within the limits is that i don't want
to um dox anybody yeah and so
but there's ways to get around that um
you know
i can uh just just interject because you
know for a lot of people who are just
tuning in
i have uh independently i i guess you
could say independently corroborated
at least well you know i
you i don't know what you can say no so
you sides at me and i showed you some
things and you made an evaluation based
on that
after i saw it i went and did some
uh general sleuthing and was able to
independently corroborate through
different databases and it was it's very
interesting
more than once so uh i think he found
something i mean i guess we'll see how
it plays out in
the courts but uh i do think it's it's
shocking i mean we
we we kicked off this conversation
reading through you know this response
from these other states saying
that there's no evidence and that to me
is shocking considering i just
corroborated something
i'll put it that way and i corroborated
the corroborators right
can we play a middle ground here and say
how excited
or surprised were you from some of the
findings we don't have to discuss the
findings but
maybe your level of uh excitement or
shock well i'll tell you you know
um i don't think you could i
i was surprised by certain things that i
found
um and not surprised by other things uh
i said in on on video without going into
detail that
i believe that in enough states there
were enough
potentially legal ballots to surpass the
margins
and thus cast into doubt in my mind
whether or not uh joe biden's the
deserved winner now i've i've said that
publicly don't have a problem really
repeating that
um but there were some things that
decided to be some and you know not just
about the data but also the process
this journey up but we'll clarify too
like we're not at the point where that's
definitive it's just
signs and indications perhaps i
i'll save that one for later there you
go all right where does this go from
here what's the next process what are we
waiting for
how is this going to play out well right
now it's um
it's in the hands of the lawyers the
judges uh the legislators
um i'm just at the point now where i
answer questions about my findings
and potentially you know answer other
questions as they come up
um so from my perspective the the base
research has been
done and completed we're just you know
giving lawyers affidavits and
declarations and
uh potentially testifying here and there
is is this in any way related i don't
know
feel free to not answer effect if you
can't uh if you can't is this in any way
related to the state's
filing suits um i'm not going to answer
that
i can't answer that right now but that's
that's this question i'm happy to answer
uh with a brief delay right on
well it's it's uh i'm happy you're here
okay but it is you know it's it's
walking a fine line because i'm like
i would uh probably be extremely upset
if something happened from this show you
know in a lawsuit where they're like
we're gonna cite you know the tim castro
podcast where matt brainard said this
and then all of a sudden it's like
in case it's missed or something so uh i
guess for the people who are listening i
have no choice
uh we have no choice but to just try and
you know graze
this as best we can without ruining
everything i think they i think they
support that too
because i'm pretty sure people would be
calling for my head on uh
well i gotta be careful about the
language i use people would be calling
for
uh your beanie and a spike yes my beanie
they're taking some meaning
he had to do this show we're observing
the bannon rule here i see
yes oh definitely man well listen listen
youtube has already
so let's let's do this this is actually
an excellent opportunity to go into uh
we have we have
the big news with tulsi gabbard uh it's
called the breakup what is it called
break up big tech
act uh the bubta uh she's saying
these companies should not have 230
protections liability protections
if they're censoring people so just in
inter we'll go into this in just a brief
second
this is the uh story from newsweek tulsi
gabbard backs trump in section 230
battle accuses lawmakers of cow towing
to big tech so
we've already seen and this story is
from you know a couple days ago but
on youtube right now they just announced
a new rule about what you can and can't
say pertaining to
uh donald trump and accusations of fraud
it's really weird we had a really funny
discussion before the show
about like so i don't even know if i can
say
the uh the actual criteria because it
might be an algorithm just listens and
then
nukes the show because i said something
too similar but i'll i'll try and break
it up
i actually spoke with google on the
phone they said two criteria must be met
for a video to be removed
you must assert that there is widespread
voter fraud or error in this election
the next criteria that must be claimed
in the same sentence is that it changed
the outcome of the election
and that's it i asked for clarification
what about changing the outcome in terms
of like
you know point one versus you know uh
you know minus point one like
the like the the winner isn't changed
but the numbers are changed and they
said
i think it's basically like if you claim
trump actually won because of these
reasons
and i'm like okay so if i say there is
evidence of widespread fraud
um and it needs to be investigated
but there's not it's not yet been as far
as i can tell
proven beyond a reasonable doubt that it
altered the outcome they said that's
okay
now i'm not entirely convinced that's
the case they may still nuke us for even
discussing it because
we don't know who these third-party
outsourced individuals who are reviewing
you know transcripts
what they're going to understand i get
routinely flagged for like ridiculous
things you know i did a segment talking
about
i was it was about some policy position
the video was like you know
joe biden plans policy around x and they
said it was hate speech and then what i
have to do is i have to actually reach
out to google
and they do a secondary review and
overturn personally
because i guess they like me you know
maybe maybe they won't ban me
but these what they have third party
fact checkers they're
you know in a bunch of different
countries all over the place because
youtube's massive
and they just here's the rule sheet and
they say yes or no
and so that's just bizarre though that
the total political discussion our
country is governed by
their uh third world outsourced that's
exactly it that they found on fiverr.com
their fiverr.com workforce is
regulating our political speech or
robotic algorithms that take things out
of context
yes and can't understand sarcasm so
you know well they also i don't know if
we should even joke about it we had a
really funny joke earlier and i'm like i
don't know if i could actually say that
they still might
yeah i don't even know i can make the
joke because the joke might still
get to like a point of power it's just
time to stop joking i think
when you talk about certain things but
but there's like
so there are certain jokes that are
obvious jokes to anybody but not to an
algorithm
because there there's intonation there's
inflection oh we should do a whole show
like you could you could say something
like
you could say so i'll give half the joke
of course
joe biden won he's the greatest
president in american history
already people are gonna hear them
they're gonna get on being sarcastic
he's not the greatest
so that's the joke i was making in the
other episodes with like joe biden
doesn't campaign he gets eight million
votes and he's like wow
think about the amount of charisma just
exuding an aura
it's almost like if you're familiar with
dragon ball z how many dragon ball z
fans are out there
you know goku and he goes ah and there's
like a blast of energy coming out of his
body
joe biden stood up on that podium and
with one wink to that camera
it was like a nuclear bomb exploded
behind him the charisma was just people
sitting in their homes watching their tv
got knocked back like
stuck against the wall with the amount
of charisma that's how joe biden was
able to not campaign and win 80 million
votes
how are they going to campaign with when
the neural nets activated
i have no idea when we're all linked and
you won't need to because we'll be the
borg
i guess you just you you already know
who you're going to vote for before they
even decide they're going to run
they're going to ban you from the neural
net so you're going to be one of like
you're going to be one of these like
um i don't know non-networked
individuals
and they're going to frown upon you and
you're going to be like outside
asking people just spare a little
internet can you google search something
for me
obviously the process will change
leading up to technology like that so
maybe we're just
in a fluctual process right now the the
issue is the unpersoning
and the and the suspension of political
discourse and especially
by non-american actors so i'll check
this out check this out
if you go on reddit.com and you go to r
slash politics
which is supposed to be t it's basically
for american politics
more than half the people who are
commenting are probably in australia and
new zealand and europe
maybe not more than half but a good
portion so that means
americans are hearing more from foreign
opinions on our elections
and american citizens get suspended so
this is what i find is particularly
crazy and i'll use laura loomer as an
example
she ran she won her primary in florida
she's
a very controversial figure but she's
very good at getting press attention
she's been banned from every platform
but she is an american citizen who was
running for office and won a primary
still banned from all these platforms
but on twitter you can have
a hundred thousand people from australia
telling us how we should vote what we
what we should think influencing our
elections i'm not saying illegally
influencing
but that is worrying to me that these
people who don't live here
who don't understand the electoral
college who don't understand how our
representation works
don't understand how gerrymandering
works are influencing
people's opinions in negative ways
without understanding our country
that to me is terrifying especially when
you when you consider a lot of these big
tech platforms
like the risk we face right now by
having this conversation they've said
they'll ban it well that's not gonna
affect any democrat the democrats are
saying republicans are crazy
but there's there's there's evidence and
there's discussions to be had
they could ban us so that's negatively
impacting
conversations typically of the right yet
if you are australian
and you agree with democrats you can say
whatever you want but american citizen
can't
that's insane
yeah yeah i'm absolutely just sick of
this like land
mine system where you have to be careful
with every little thing you say i mean
on my channel
i have to say the conhole sickness and
the jab instead of the con
coronavirus and vaccine and i noticed
the significant difference
through my videos and the way that they
reach people when i say conholio
sickness
instead of coronavirus so there's
different algorithms there's different
people there's people in third world
countries that are literally hired
that have found to have a bias against
the lgbtq community
and there was a big outrage because a
whole bunch of like
trendy new wave woke craters were
getting censored and they're like what's
going on here
and it was a guy who was a religious
zealot in a third-world country who
hated them for for what they were well
we need to when you think about the
results of what's currently happening
with social media so everything i just
said about how
an australian citizen has more rights
because typically their opinions are
more likely to align with the democrats
right
so the u.s relative to europe and
australia is actually a bit to the right
and a lot of people keep saying in
europe america is so far right
the democrats are considered like a
centrist party compared to europe
and it's like i don't i'm not concerned
about the opinions of europeans because
they don't understand our system they
don't live here
and they don't under like there's a lot
of things they don't get about our
history
why we have the certain systems we do
it's not like one day we woke up and
said we want to create a broken weird
medical system
they had world war ii we had we all had
world war ii but they were most impacted
and they were they were forced
essentially to create some kind of
system to fix this
it doesn't apply here but here what ends
up happening is
jack dorsey on the jorgen podcast said
we have to create rules for a global
community
and that means people in america who are
to the right of people in other
countries
may offend their delicate sensibilities
so twitter says
what's in the best interest of
maximizing our profits
we don't want just american users we
want european users so we can't defend
european users so ban those who offend
european users
democrats tend to offend them much much
less than conservatives so ban the
conservatives
now we can't have conversations in our
own country because they've
overtaken what's called the commons the
space where we used to communicate and
talk about public discourse and
it's not just us and it's not just
random individuals but it's also
major uh journalistic institutions in
the united states like the new york post
that are literally having their accounts
taken away
for days because they release on a story
that now everyone is reporting on but
because the story was before the
election it was about hunter biden it
was about the son
of the democratic hopeful at the time
new york post got
censored and totally wiped off twitter
no one could even communicate with them
well
it is most um major evolutions that
become problems like this are are almost
always the result of certain government
policies creating
for example in this case a moral hazard
here's the moral hazard and here's how
it was created
is that they have the ability
to censor anyone they want but they
don't have the responsibility
for what is published on their site so
they they have
all the power but none of the
responsibility that comes with it
and the way 230 was designed and all
these things you either have one or the
other so let's say um
let's say you and i plot some a criminal
scheme and we talk to each other over
t-mobile the t-mobile network right
well t-mobile didn't censor us they
didn't publish us they're sort of you
know
so they're not you can't sue t-mobile
for if somebody's a victim of our crime
they can't sue t-mobile for
being part of it right so that's the
protection that makes sense for team
now if t-mobile started listening on
conversations and saying that's not an
appropriate conversation for you to have
well you think well now they have to
accept responsibility for what they're
lying or not alone
but what these socials have right now is
they have all the power
and other responsibility and one of
those two things has to go away the
problem's going to continue to get worse
and that's kind of the 230 reform we
need is that
look you are either a publisher yeah and
you have responsibility which is fine
but ban everybody but then if somebody
plot some scheme through your site well
you're completely on the hook for it and
that's the kind of reform that yeah i
think we need to look at so for those
that aren't familiar just to clarify
section 230 of the communications
decency act
says that no uh platform shall be
considered to be the publisher
of someone else's speech to simplify if
you go on twitter
and post a comment or tweet that's your
speech not twitter's
i completely and 100 agree with it like
if i make a phone call and and you know
if i group
call a hundred people and then i say
some naughty word
that's not on t-mobile t-mobile is just
a phone company
it's my speech i said something if i
call people start defaming someone you
sue me right
the issue is as you described it
translating this to twitter uh or to
youtube actually
youtube statements about what we can or
can't say pertaining to the election
is an editorial guideline not a
community standard now they've said it
was a community standard but that makes
no sense
no uh if 74 million people agree with
one idea and 80 million people don't
we clearly don't have a unified societal
concept like what is lewd in lascivious
section 230 provides what's called a
good samaritan provision for moderation
these platforms like youtube are allowed
to remove things and not be considered a
publisher
because it's good faith moderation if
someone posts
you know adult activities onto twitter
and twitter doesn't want that then
section 230 says we're not going to
we're not going to consider you the
publisher because you're choosing to get
rid of these things that are
otherwise objectionable this is where
the problem arises
the language objectionable in section
230
define it that's the problem well
twitter or youtube would say
we think it's objectionable that anyone
would question the election
70 74 million people would disagree in
fact probably more than that because
there's been a couple polls now showing
that even democrats believe their their
their there was fraud
and most republicans do so it's more
than 74 million
so when youtube says we find it
objectionable
perhaps under section 230 objectionable
could be a personal opinion in which
case
they are granted absolute and total
immunity as a publisher
to issue editorial guidelines on what
may or may not be published and never
face liabilities
which not even the new york times gets
you got to change the word objectionable
to illegal
yes and then you got to pick what state
that's in and i think
right and typically the law would say
like the state
at which the company is registered or
whatever but yes
so that way there is a challenge there
right
but i think you can define lewd
lascivious
and we're not going to say a challenging
election is lewd that makes no sense
we're not going to say it's
offensive you might be able to argue
that but that still kind of doesn't make
a whole lot of sense and a judge might
be like what do you mean it's offensive
no it's not
objectionable means anything and that's
the reform we need
we need to get rid of that word salute
lascivious like if someone pulls out
their
genitals well think about it this way
let's say uh the example i think we were
given by one of the guests was a
christian blog
a website where christians and catholics
or whatever can come and have
conversations
and then someone starts posting a bunch
of adult activities
right well they're going to be like we
don't watch on our platform it's not for
this it's so that we can have you know
our
our conversations then they're a
publisher then right
you can remove all that and still be
protected because it's clearly not in
the spirit it's a good samaritan
change privilege to say if only illegal
content then they couldn't remove that
without becoming a publisher exactly
well so if you got rid of objectionable
with illegal then
they could still remove it because lewd
lascivious filthy or otherwise
objectionable there's a few other words
in there
so the the the issue i suppose is
there is absolutely illegal content you
could remove and i think the simple
solution that a lot of people presented
is
the block function if you are on twitter
and someone posts something
objectionable twitter should just be
like well you can block them
that's it i think that advertisers
threatening to pull their money is a big
impetus for why
it goes proactively removing content
that's that's actually the reason
they're doing this
and that's why google so when i first
saw youtube's statement about
we can't question the election kind of
stuff the full report is actually about
like advertisers
and friendly content and so they're like
we're removing things
they they're worried that advertisers
will freak out upon seeing this and it's
typical
typically because youtube is scared of
the new york times and the wall street
journal the wall street journal targeted
pewdiepie youtube lost so much money
i would love to see this in court i
would love to see susan woginski and
youtube sitting there
and saying you can't say the election is
a fraud
unless it's so four years ago
so so yes right yeah you can say but no
i was told you can't say that
exactly i was told that the hillary
clinton trump election was considered
historic
so long as the election is historic you
cannot question it uh
you can't say two criteria the one i
explained before one you
if you say there's widespread fraud and
then two you claim it altered the
outcome that is bannable but
if you said something like an alien
invasion caused
you know the change the outcome of the
election that's totally fine but they'll
shadow ban you
no oh i'm sure they will i mean they'll
shut up and you for everything and
they'll derank everything but the point
is
they will straight remove content if you
meet this criteria didn't you say
there's a bunch of stuff about hillary
um getting all over yeah i mean the
atlantic has a video about how the
election was stolen
the new york times cnn they have tons of
videos about all the stuff everywhere
all over youtube
that's the problem section 230 has
created
this this uh it's almost like
the system they've created tends towards
what is considered mainstream and
acceptable
and so people are chasing each other as
canceled culture starts attacking the
right and getting them banned
increasingly accusing one side of being
offensive or objectionable
then social media gets scared because
advertisers get scared and gets rid of
it moving everything further and further
not necessarily to the left towards a
broken
fractured algorithmic paranoid
delusional state so you're the best way
you're going to have to remove shadow
banning too
if you're going to shadow shadow banning
would be which means you're going to
have to free the software code because
you can't know
well you can't rely on a company to have
good faith without knowing what they're
doing the courts could review it
so they could have to submit to an
oversight committee and then who's
overseeing it man that's the problem you
would need the code because the code is
meant to affect
results so the result will be the
evidence of the code and the policy of
shadow banning you could be proof
shadow banning exists because shadow
banning works um but would it need to be
public
would a company need to publish their
proprietary code to prove that they're
doing the good thing the right thing
uh well no because if they're doing it
it's evident in the results
right what you can see it's because what
would be the point of the code if it
didn't reveal what it was the point of
shadow banning is that you can't see it
no no but you know shadow bending is
happening but you don't know that's the
point no you do it becomes banning when
you know it's happening we
don't know what's happening there are
numerous third-party programs
that can verify shadow banning very very
easily like what
so uh what's the one that everyone uses
the european ones that it's a dot eu
it's shadowband.eu i think and you type
in a twitter name and press enter and
it'll tell you every restriction place
in your account would be that simple it
would be empirically
um reviewable the evidence would be that
you just set up a couple
of other accounts ask people to follow
you do a statistical analysis of how
often you show up in the timeline
etc it will be because i i follow people
who i believe are shadow band i have the
you know it's something you could
statistically prove to court and it's
pretty much open and shut not only that
uh when it when they shadow banned i
think ronald mcdaniel from twitter
search
it was plainly obvious to literally
everybody but like on youtube if you're
getting 10 000 views then all of a
sudden you're getting 9 000 views
how can you prove that they're not that
they didn't 90
your algorithm well i think you're
thinking about youtube in a ba backwards
youtube isn't necessarily shadow banning
they're algorithmically promoting some
content and dis de promoting others not
demoting
or not promoting at all is a better way
to put it on twitter it's a reverse
chronological feed meaning
if i follow you and you post at 10 59
a.m i should get your tweet in my feed
at 10 59
a.m but sometimes twitter shadow bands
people on that tweet won't appear
so on youtube if i publish a video you
should get a notification that's
it youtube promotes the content and they
choose who they promote so i actually
think
you know in that sense youtube has no
obligation to promote me
if people don't watch my content then i
don't know it does create a problem
because
they're they're actively promoting
certain content which makes them in my
opinion a publisher
if youtube says we have identified
content that we
make sure appears on the front page
think about it this way buzzfeed has a
community
section or they used to i don't know if
they still do where anybody can write
and it gets posted
but they'll they they're not going to
put that on the front page the front
page is where
their authors and staffers appear
sometimes i think community post
might but i don't think so buzzfeed
community posts i don't know if they
still do it we're always very much like
you could write a story
and then publish it on youtube well
youtube's
the biggest site uh the second biggest
search engine in the world
they are choosing based on certain
criteria to publish your content to the
front page
to people who have not subscribed
youtube is a publisher and not a
platform and even when you're all your
people that you're subscribed to if
you're subscribed to a thousand accounts
youtube chooses which of those thousand
accounts you're going to see
yes and that makes them a publisher
absolutely well you know there's there's
a counter
we were talking about reform section
213. so unfortunately uh representative
gallup
gabbard's she's out she didn't run for
election so somebody's going to be
taking her seat
and she's done but there's there's other
means because you brought up the
advertising angle one thing i've
advocated for
is that there are a lot of states out
there with large constituencies who
don't like
people with conservative viewpoints
being just banned for perfectly legal
speech
um i don't see a reason why state
shouldn't start implementing laws that
the state itself and all the
municipalities within it are forbidden
from buying advertising
on platforms that censor legal speech
wow
so that would that would maybe get there
no maybe that's a bold law though
is it or isn't it because it's pretty
straightforward is it it and it's very
justifiable that look i
in the state of south carolina i'm a
let's say i was i was living there
i'm a taxpayer right and i'm funding the
government do i want that
government handing money to buy
advertising you're saying that the
government can't buy advertising the
government cannot buy advertising and
politicians well i don't know about
elected officials that that's that's
more of a free speech issue but
the um any government agency because
they spend a lot of money on these
socials they
promote advertising no government agency
within the state is allowed to spend
money
if they sent you the speech of our
constitution because i'm paying money to
the state government
uh youtube or twitter is banning me
because i said i don't know there's only
two genders or whatever
and and they'll ban you yeah right and
then they're giving and my money's going
from the state to
twitter that that's unconscionable
because they're censoring my legal
speech
okay upon clarification you are 100
correct and i think every state should
implement that of course
will any of them actually do anything
i'm not maybe i believe that
i'm working on some projects in the
upcoming year i think that that will be
on the agenda i believe there are at
least seven look
if you can get a state to sue another
four states the supreme court over
presidential election
i think you can get i think you can get
a state to at
that on the sovereign level say that
look we're not spending any more money
on any social network
that censors legal it's a very it's not
they don't have to even name this
places they just have to establish that
standard and it's like well you know
the only thing how do they determine
which falls under the criteria
would someone bring a complaint to the
state saying if
so you know you'd go there and say hi i
was banned by twitter for
this and they would say therefore by
this one tweet all advertising is
canceled to twitter
i think that the the legislation could
encount you know could work around that
to fundamentally get at the general
ideas that
if it they may only have to cite the
policy
of twitter saying what that's what they
do or a well-publicized case
and you know we've seen this before
because you remember state of california
i think
banned doing any business with the state
of uh indiana or anything that had a
bathroom
there right no no i think it was a
bathroom stuff
or something like that i think it was
gay marriage i thought it was bathroom
but maybe it's
whatever yeah it's probably all of them
actually maybe yeah that's very
important but i like this idea i don't
want tax dollars going to financing some
of these companies that clearly do have
a bias and do have an agenda another
thing to really kind of think about here
especially when it comes to the
advertisers and
supposedly these companies bowing down
to the pressure of the advertisers in
the mainstream media
is that advertisers have a choice to
make when they choose advertising they
could choose to advertise on let's say
the alex jones show or they could
exclude them
just like me as a producer i could go on
my adsense and i could say
i don't want any mcdonald's monsanto us
military
politician ads on my channel which i did
before when
i was still in the partner program
advertisers could still do that
themselves
and i don't know why there's not a
bigger emphasis by saying hey if you
don't like them
just put them in your google adsense
account then you don't want to advertise
them and then you don't have to ban that
person you could just block them
imagine 10 years ago someone listening
to your phone calls and shutting off
your phone service because they didn't
like what you said
this is this this is the society that
we're going to
it's dangerous and there's so much power
by these individuals that needs to be
checked immediately well you know where
it came from
is that left-wing activists
gather together rabble rousers to target
companies with just
hit them with emails phone calls tweet
at them the company not realizing in
most cases these people are not only not
their customers but would never be their
customers
start to panic and they're like and then
they call youtube and said hey we can't
advertise
with you anymore because all these
people are blowing up our timeline
so you got to stop you know having you
know this guy on your youtube channel
because he he said something
controversial
and then they you know that's how we get
to this policy because honestly if no
advertiser ever threatened to pull ads
from a social media network
i don't think jack dorsey those guys
would but they could just easily say
okay guys if you if you're if you're
coming at me we're just going to make
sure we never advertise remember
but hold on you're missing one extra
component after the email campaign
the activists will then send a tip to an
ally at a news organization
who will then write did you agree that
the racism on your
you were advertising it was bad and so
what happens is
they'll get a bunch of emails and i've
i've seen these threats
uh we were we were putting on a speaking
event last year and antifa called a
self-identified anti-fascist threatened
to burn the theater down
so naturally these people freak out but
one of the calls that went to a local
business was we're going to make sure
the news finds out you're supporting
white supremacists
so what happens then is this company
goes i got all these emails
they then told me i was doing something
wrong they then said they're going to
send to the press
one of these activists i mean they all
work in media they got jobs there
will then be like ooh here's a juicy
story and then they'll email this
company and say
so i actually i actually broke this
story where a reporter for slate
sent a what i would describe as a veiled
threat to
a bank to get the proud boys uh a
principal proud boy member banned
by saying why is it that you support
white supremacy is this a
known thing something that affect and
the bank was like no no no we don't we
don't we don't we don't it's gone it's
gone
because the journalist is essentially
saying i'm gonna write a story accusing
you of supporting white supremacy
and then watch people panic and sell
your shares the other thing that happens
in this
is that if conservatives do the same
thing you know the journalist will write
a hoax campaign by fringe far-right
extremists
targeted this company and they valiantly
defied them
because the right doesn't have a foot in
these cultural institutions
and because a lot of these ad buyers
just read the new york times the wall
street journal
the right can't counter it the same way
the left does and i think that companies
like vanguard
state street and black i think it's
black rock is the name of them these
three largest investment firms in the
world
own 20 of alphabet or google so
it's not just like toyota that would
pull their ads from
you know luke rutkowski's videos if he
mentions the federal reserve but it's
blackrock and state street uh will pull
their funding from alphabet
and then that company will fall apart
these companies own eight percent of
apple eight percent of microsoft eight
percent of google
yeah blackrock is one of the largest
asset management firms in the world they
have about seven trillion dollars and
they just recently started investing in
the chinese stock market
so literally people's pensions and
retirements and and
money in their bank account literally is
investing into china right now
and the federal reserve is bailing out
blackrock with any loss they have the
federal reserve is just making sure that
they get covered
socialism for the super rich when they
make a profit they get to keep all their
income
they lose federal reserve literally
steps in and is funneling money into
them blackrock is
a big institution that we should talk
about let's combine our disdain for
the activists in media with our uh
disdain for big tech censorship with
probably one of the most consequential
stories of our generation
hunter biden is under criminal
investigation for possible money
laundering and illicit business deals
with china
that was partially facilitated by his
own father in his role as the vice
president
this story was suppressed was censored
and blocked
across social media npr said it wasn't
really news it was a distraction
politico said in fact 50 intelligence
officials former intelligence officials
said it was russian disinformation
cnn said the same thing and so to msnbc
and now politico has the gall
to publish the story that oops hunter
biden
justice department's interest and hunter
button covered more than taxes so here
we finally get it
and i love this when they say it is a is
a powerful well i guess they updated the
story recently
but they say it was an explosive
explosive political revelations
revelations that um the american people
needed to know about before they cast
their ballots
and revelations that the media as well
as big tech companies suppressed
that is probably the most um
dystopian thing i've ever a story i've
ever read think about that right now
in in the time frame we are in we are
being told
vice former vice president joe biden is
the president-elect
he's not until january 6th the official
uh uh
you know youtube has said that there's
enough electors to
you know determine that he is and
whatever on january 6 is when
officially under the constitution we get
our president-elect we're sitting here
being told that's the case
and now we're being told oh and by the
way we knew he was crooked we knew he
was corrupt and compromised
and we didn't tell you and we're telling
you now because we want you to sit here
and wait
wait for a month knowing that we
royally you over and that you are going
to have a crooked
corrupt crony compromised politician
running the show and there is nothing
you can do to stop it that
i think twitter um censoring the new
york post was the most scandalous thing
they've ever done
yeah and it's important to note here the
new york post was the one that released
the story they're the ones who came out
and said hey the oldest newspaper in
this country
yep and then what was the response the
mainstream media obfuscated it ignored
it laughed at it made up total lies out
of nowhere no evidence
needed former intelligence officials say
it's russian disinfo
exactly it's russian interference and
literally
there's no merit there's no evidence
there's no data there's no documents
there was
absolutely nothing you know you know
there's photographs
of hunter biden getting off of air force
two yeah and it's not just hunter biden
it's also the federal authorities are
also looking into other relatives
including joe biden's brother
james who the federal authorities are
looking into and asking about a specific
bankruptcy when it comes to another
business that he had we got the story
right here from the new york post
the feds are probing joe biden's brother
james report says
it is the biden family and tony
babilinski a former confidant of the
family
said in no uncertain terms that he
believes the biden family is compromised
by china
so they suppressed this story and there
was a poll that was put out
one by the media research center and
another i can't remember it was more of
a
you know more bland poll from like abc
or something where they found that
a decent amount of people a small
percentage maybe four to five said they
would not have voted for joe biden had
they known what his son and brother had
been doing
but the media suppressed the news and
helped joe biden a corrupt politician
win
and now what are americans supposed to
do when they come out with this
information
i'll tell you if the news just broke
right now and they were like we just
found this out i mean that would be
shocking
but when we know that the media said
well we suppressed the story we lied
about it and big tech censored it
to make sure he won even though they
knew he's a criminal
it wasn't even that like msnbc didn't
run a story on it
twitter took they deleted stories about
it
they they they suspended the new york
post's twitter account for weeks
so they couldn't report anything because
they dare oppose oppose them
and they told the new york post delete
the tweet delete
the article you'll get your account back
they didn't they luckily stood up to
their morals but for how long were they
taken out of business
out of commission from even people
seeing and sharing and understanding
this larger news which was important
context to understand
especially on the backdrop of the
beijing professor that came out and
hinted
that chinese authorities were the ones
that he said
yes he said who built biden's wealth and
then everyone laughs and he goes got it
yeah specifically talking about hunter
and his son and
trump's criticism of it which is major
no need
not to guild the lily here but we
actually had this exact situation
in reverse not that long ago but the
meteor acted very
differently you may recall when sarah
palin was the vice presidential nominee
her emails were hacked yup and leaked
newspapers assigned reporters round the
clock to go through
every single one of them and report on
every single possible detail that now
they didn't find anything at all because
it's completely clean it's just you know
dance recitals and whatever for kids but
they they went armpit
deep in that whereas now there's this
this the laptop shows up right
legally the possession of the guy who
shared it the
shop owner he legally owns that laptop
because of the lien biden didn't pay it
off
and it's just what happened here i think
is part of a reaction to um
what happened in 16 where coverage of
the fbi investigation
was what they think through the election
to hillary and no journalists wanted to
be that one journalist
who came out and reported this story and
potentially do the election back to
trump the peer pressure among them was
so strong
i remember communicating with
journalists just in a couple weeks
leading up to the election but there's
some
you know i'm often trying to seed
stories or pitch stories and get stuff
out there
and there was one story that would have
made biden look
very bad not too but not not hyped or
not not laptop bad but in that realm
right
and ordinarily a story of this nature
would be snapped right up
but there were no takers and i talked
about democrats it clearly is and
we can't we can no longer suffer under
the illusion that the media's
uh you know some kind of non-bias some
there the referee here
um it's it's almost it's almost
redundant it's almost tired of hearing
these people making the case oh look at
what you know of course you know the
double standard yeah yeah
it's like wwe right where it's like the
ref joins in the fight like two guys are
fighting and then
someone accidentally hits the ref and
the ref gets in and now the ref is
fighting like what's going on
it's just not real right the new york
times is is not a
newspaper it's a pr agency for hard life
democrats
yes it's a pr agent so is em cnn ms
they're all they're pr
so uh and anyone feel free to answer
this if
i would have told you two years ago that
if i said in 2018 you know in a couple
of years half the country
20 states and two territories would be
uh
let me rephrase this if i told you in
2018 that 18 states
were suing to effectively
change the results of the 2020 election
and 20 other states filed briefs
challenging them
paying half the country against the
other half would you believe that i
would have believed you you would have
yeah especially if you told me they were
mail-in ballots
no no i just just that the states are
lining up this divisive as trump was i
would have believed you
what about you guys i mean there was a
lot of street fights between
left-wing and right-wing people so there
was in indications that there was going
to be a larger conflict but not this big
not somewhere where states are going
after when i was talking about the
potential for
conflict people kept saying the states
will never be against each other it
makes no sense
and now they are now i bring this up
because
the media does not represent the people
they represent
their side we have states aligned
against states
20 20 plus two territories against 18 on
the other side and the president
you have a media apparatus that is lying
left and right about everything and the
big tech companies defending those lies
dude i gotta amend my statement i would
have thought you were fear-mongering
there's no way i would have believed you
i would've been like tim come on this is
what
people obsessive i i remember earlier
this year it's funny what's funny to me
is
you know uh there's a temple bingo card
you know it's like when tim paul says
something take a drink because there's
like a handful of things that will bring
up
civil war was one of them yeah and and
so when i mentioned on the show
um i think you know two months ago that
i think i've talked about civil war
in specific videos it does it a couple
dozen times and in passing maybe a
couple hundred times i had these
leftists you know put up all these you
know claims saying temple's lying he's
obsessed with civil war whatever
and accuse me of like you know just
fear-mongering or whatever
and it's like my response was the
narrative
started with a princeton professor who
was a democrat who said we are in a cold
civil war
and i was like wow that's crazy so i
talked about it we had uh analysis from
several uh security advisors excuse me
who i can't remember in new york or the
atlantic where they said
ranging from 30 to 90 possibility of a
civil war based on the tensions
and the the aggregate analysis like when
they averaged out everyone's opinions it
was like a 35
chance and then we saw the street fights
we saw charlottesville we saw all of
this chaos and conflict
and if after all of that i said in two
years
20 states 18 states would be filing a
suit against four and then 20 would join
in to counter that
because they refused the results of the
election people absolutely would have
been like you're insane
you know i had people telling me that
the proud boys fighting antifa would
stop
there they're like you don't get it man
you think that this is going to escalate
it's just the proud boys and and antifa
they're fringe groups
and i said what happens when people who
know them
who know the antifa guy hear the story
about what happened and then blame the
right and the people who know the proud
boys so a proud white goes home he's got
a black eye and he says oh these
anti-guys attacked me
now his friends hear it it spreads to
family and friends then what do we see
in new york
regular new yorkers were throwing bricks
and rocks at cars flying trump flags
and a woman went up to a vehicle and
pepper sprayed
children and they still say to me yeah
but that's just regular people fighting
and then i say but listen now it's going
to the highest levels they're trying to
impeach the president on ridiculous
meritless grounds they have put a former
general
in in the crosshairs of prison michael
flynn this is one of the highest ranking
military positions in the country and
they're going to lock him up for
nothing for lying to the fbi a
potentially informal meeting
and when one side when the doj said
we're gonna get rid of this the judge
said
no you you see from the highest levels
they're trying to arrest a general and
at the lowest levels you have people
fighting in the streets
and now 20 versus 18 states in a lawsuit
saying that's not my president
i don't know where this goes and maybe
it stops right now i'm just saying i
think because of the context it's not as
bad as it seems with the panel
people are nuts because they've been
locked up they don't hate each other
really
charlottesville there's going to be
there was no pandemic
yeah i mean there's going to be
especially in the united states where
you're allowed to go out and protest and
own guns there's going to be
little bits of like explosive little
bits violence only a few months
ago in some countries two trump
supporters and put two bullets in some
countries that stuff couldn't happen
because the government would crack down
kill and arrest everyone involved and
you'd never see any
so perhaps we have that weakness in that
strength yeah i mean you could well it
depends the government decides what
protests to crack down on
and they have been selective about that
when it comes to a particular protest
they like they let it happen if they
don't like the protest they crack down
on it do you think so so listen
i'm gonna say that's what i want to be
very clear here at a certain point
when i'm saying i think street violence
is going to spread
and it's going to affect people in the
culture war will exacerbate
people say no i think you're crazy then
it happens
and they say well tim's still crazy then
i say i didn't predict
18 states filing a suit to challenge
four states which overturned the
election and 20 states
firing back or you know michael flynn
they're trying to lock up a general
that's like
trying to arrest and imprison a general
because
he he essentially ratted on the obama
administration's illicit activities in
the middle east
and then he went to work with trump i
mean this is some highest level stuff
all the way down to the lowest level my
point is when we then get to a point
where you have 20 versus 18 states
i don't know if it escalates further
from here but i can say for the time
being
i was right about the escalation there's
every step of the way there's an ominous
parallel for you
uh you know i'm not sure where it goes
it's division in this country is
um very dangerous but you may recall the
last time you know there was a civil war
in this country
and you may recall that uh just look at
the language
there were two sides right what was the
how would you define the two sides
there were the what states and the what
states the pro and anti-slavery
right um now look at where we are now
have we developed that terminology all
over again another
dichotomy what is it red states and blue
states
we've built a division into the country
that's been festering since
2000 where it starts it wasn't no you
know it wasn't any longer
they used to call you know the states in
the south uh east
um the uh you know former confederacy
and for a while they were solid democrat
states and that sort of changed and it
became now we've got a new
phrase to divide ourselves just like the
the mason-dixon slave states free states
we have a new dividing terminology um
that was not around like in the 80s and
90s there was south carolina kansas
georgia
sometimes the democrats want them
sometimes it didn't but now we have this
firm division we have blue states
we have red states and there's more
people don't understand what a civil war
is
because they're tainted by american
american history
in american history we had states which
were part of a union and so
there was an alignment on some issues
and not in many other countries
actually every single country civil war
was like pockets of urban areas versus
rural areas
and then there were fights over
territories and control of one
government
in the united states you actually had a
secession and then the union saying
we're not gonna let the country break
apart
the south wasn't necessarily trying to
take over the north
they were trying to get into dc to
effectively end the war but they wanted
their states to be out of the union
very different for what we've seen in
perhaps the spanish civil war
one of the key components in civil
conflict whether it's a civil war
or tribalist feuding and fighting
whatever is
a view that the other is irredeemable
and evil
and wrong we have as i mentioned 18
versus 20 states right now
and i'm sure many people on the left and
and many of these people have repeatedly
said nothing's happening over and over
again as things have escalated
i'll say it again maybe it stops here
okay but it's crazy to me that from
two years ago till today they kept
saying it won't happen it won't happen
and it keeps getting worse
but here's the most important point a
hashtag was trending today on twitter
seditious17 and esquire magazine has
wrote has written this article
the republican party is now a seditious
organization
these authoritarian yahoos believe the
supreme court will ride to the rescue
and disenfranchise millions of people
whom they don't believe should be
allowed to vote anyway
they are now officially stating that all
of these states are seditious
that's like some crap news organization
esquire magazine yeah
somebody owns that i'm trying to make a
bunch of money off of it it doesn't
matter
the sentiment now exists he already
mentioned you know matt mentioned red
and blue states
the tribes basically exist there have
been attempts at breaking down what the
left and the right is and it makes no
sense because policy agreements don't
define it
my policy-wise on economics i'm actually
decently left
but in terms of cultural issues in the
culture where i'm clearly right
so where am i hetero heterodox i suppose
but clearly there is a dividing line
between the factions
both are calling each other traitorous
and evil and i just got to stress this
you know to the utmost agree when people
talk about this
has anyone i think we're in the pot
boiling and so we don't realize how
serious it is
that they tried to put a former general
in prison
like that right there should be a huge
indicator that something is seriously
going wrong in this country
they said that donald trump and when he
had the rallies chanting lock her up
that's terrifying they're going to go
after a political rival like that
and then it was michael flynn who served
this country and as luke
you know uh pointed out in the other
episode i guess the obama administration
was mad because he exposed that they
were arming rebels
in in syria is that that correct yeah so
of course he was uh he's the one that
whistleblowed he's the one that got
fired as the national security adviser
under barack obama that exposed the
whole game that was happening there that
solidified everything and we have to
really think about the kind of longer
bigger terms perspectives here because
if you're a force
or if you're an interest and you want to
take over another
nation or a country what's the best way
to do it you divide and conquer the
population
fifth generation yeah and that's why
i've been talking about this for 10
years i've been saying
watch out for this hyper partisan
nonsense bullcrap that's leaving
truth and any kind of logic out of the
door we have to
more than ever keep an open mind we have
to more than ever pay attention to the
truth it matters
but it doesn't matter to the special
interests that of course bastardize it
to push this larger there's a complex
war against us
the point is there is no truth clearly i
think one side is more correct than the
other
and we run the risk of getting banned
for even having these opinions what i'm
saying is on the left
they're under the impression that donald
trump is illegitimate because he was
propped up by russia
and that he's a corrupt criminal
enterprise and bill barr is his hatchet
man
clearly not and they just believe what
they're told from the media who's
clearly lying because
they've allowed hunter biden and joe
biden to get away with this very very
serious story be careful not to fall
into the trap of left and right
it's not left or right those are tribal
indicators i don't mean anything anymore
but when you just said those on the left
that was you falling into it no it's a
tribal indicator
giving into the brainwashing without
realizing it if you you met on camera
with a hundred thousand misunderstand no
i fully understand
it's easy to become the demon that we
fear
so we we should not be talking about the
left and the right and the red and the
blue and the
republicans and the we're all one people
sure
but they clearly exist and are easily
identifiable everyone knows what i mean
by the left so when we had jen perlman
on the other day she was very lovely she
was awesome to talk to we disagreed on
some issues
and she said i'm with the real left as
the economic left i agree
economically she supports cooperative
markets versus competitive markets it's
very left in terms of a political
compass sense
but in terms of what you know people in
the chat were especially
critical critiquing is the left doesn't
mean the same thing as it used to it's
now just tribal indicators red versus
blue left versus right
and although you can look at the left
and see that there are some people who
aren't super woke but still align with
them
and on the right you have people who are
disaffected liberals or intellectual
dark web types who are
hanging out with conservatives and agree
with them the the
the the separation i think is is
built upon are you a follower
of what michael malus calls the
cathedral the establishment
system or are you an independent
individual who seeks that information on
your own
both sides have independent free
thinkers the right
in my opinion and again this is my bias
tends to have more independent free
thinkers it's why you get people who
used to be left walk away
and not the other way around although
you sometimes get people who are
you know voted for trump and then say oh
no i reject that i'm left now it happens
on the left you have people who watch
the mainstream media and have no idea
what they're talking about
on the right you have regular people who
have known about the hunter biden
scandal the whole time
and are angry the media's been lying
about it granted on the right you get
people who
go too far and read crazy you know
conspiracy theories and then
they kind of lose it but i don't think
that's the majority
mainstream news as you mentioned is
essentially funky
uh functioning as a pr apparatus for
the hard left democrats it's been
weaponized well
you know i there's there's a bunch of
different reasons why this has happened
and i can talk about algorithmic
manipulation
so i i wanted to cover a story i'll let
you guys in a secret
in my opinion i'm being very careful
here on the data i analyzed in the story
i was covering years ago
the new york times seems to reuse urls
to manipulate and game facebook
algorithm facebook's algorithm
to make more money what they'll do is in
my opinion this is why they do it
they'll publish a story it's a hot news
story breaking news donald trump does
backflip
it immediately gets a hundred thousand
shares because of that youtube says
i'm sorry facebook says this is a hot
link keep showing it to people
but eventually the breaking news doesn't
really cut it anymore because everyone
knows trump did a backflip
what do they do they change the entire
article to an analysis piece about how
trump is racist
to give it an evergreen longevity
outside of breaking news
so that while facebook is promoting this
hot news story instead of having a link
die
it gets picked back up and survives
that's
huge right right so that's
a big story that i was going to be
covering but the point is
for monetary reasons they're going to
build an audience they're going to sell
a story
and it's going to keep pushing this
divide you know i guess
to simplify what i was trying to say to
luke what kicked out this conversation
is when you say we got to find the truth
i agree
but i think there is there's a reason
why they call it red pill and blue pill
i think michael malus describes it as
the red pill is
you've awoken to the reality outside of
corporate controlled media narratives
if you if you watch mainstream news
you're getting contradictory information
every other day that makes no sense
so people end up thinking crazy things
but for
those of us who've been actually
investigating and looking and reading
the news we knew hunter biden was
crooked because
we saw the emails but people who watched
cnn was told were told it was russian
disinfo
what are they going to think now when
they're now being told by cnn
that cnn was actually the ones
investigating the story the whole time
i think it was oliver darcy who said
we've been really going at this story to
try and figure out what's really going
on
so now those people who are convinced it
was russian disinfo are now being told
by the very same people
actually we were the ones who uncovered
in the first place either these peoples
that are not interested they're not uh
capable cognitively to understand what's
going on or
they're going to snap from cognitive
dissonance tim don't you know we've
always been at war with east asia
yeah yeah well also this back and forth
also makes people visit
1984 reference oh okay oh yeah yeah
you got it when i said it the first time
sorry no we have to understand
a lot of these people are just being
brought into total delusion into total
nonsense where they can't even
understand the process of independently
thinking because of the contradictory
information that just
is being thrown at them and i think it's
very clear i think we could all
understand that within the last few
years this larger divide
and conquer agenda has been there and it
has been
ranching up on so many different levels
where they i think there is
a force there is a force there's a power
that wants you fighting and hating each
other based on your skin color
based on your orientation based on your
age based on whatever you choose
to do with your own life those
differences have been
exemplified and empowered to such a
level where you see
another person you're taught to see
someone that you're going to
dislike or be angry about and to be
dysfunctional
there's there's a lot of different
fingers that we could point to to
you know people who benefit from that
whether it's the corporate world or
another geopolitical threat out there
but the most important aspect is to
first understand that it's happening
before even pointing fingers at who's
doing it well it's that it's that
division that
we see um being encouraged in so many
different places
for causing division breaking national
unity
and you know i i recall
in uh president trump's first
inauguration inaugural speech he had
a wonderful line as in is that
through loyalty to our country we will
rediscover loyalty to each other yep
and that that there says everything
because
everything that we've seen whether you
have people uh disrespecting or
what do we have to unify this right the
flag right so you want to create
division around the flag
have people kneel or be disrespectful
during the national anthem right
that's dividing people further taking
our national things that unify us
and bringing us a part of them tearing
down old monuments
or disrespect or rewriting history to
cast our founding fathers as villains
the things that are uniting us are the
things that are most under attack
and i'll i'll just go a little bit
further though in terms of what's really
the left white divide and
maybe you guys see it differently but
this is a this has been
in human history for a long time is that
and the best way to define it in
contemporary terminology is that
there are those who embrace what we now
call post-modernism
and those who reject it and i find
that's a very clean line
of mine the different ways of seeing
things and thinking things i disagree a
bit
um i've heard throughout the past
several years of the culture war
about what it's really about i've heard
it from i've heard people say it's
nationalist versus globalists i've heard
people say it's libertarian versus
authoritarian or post-modernist versus
you know
anti-post-modernist modernist and i
don't think any of these
cleanly describe what's happening i
think i think it's just world pers
it's perspective it's it's your echo
chamber i suppose and so
i got the way i think andrew breitbart
said uh uh
i'm probably gonna paraphrase paraphrase
this incorrectly but the general idea
was
that you have to walk towards the fire
you think it's
it's dangerous and it's painful but when
you pass through it you see there's
freedom on the other side of something
like that
so you have people it's the allegory of
the cave who live in the cave and people
who don't
i think that's so they're certainly um
we've had people on this show who are
decently woke
you know and have advocated for you know
rather social justice type positions
but are not what would be described as
left it's kind of strange and a lot of
people in the chat will like not like
them
but you know we've had people here who
have supported trump but also supported
social justice initiatives
that you typically would not find on the
right so
not necessarily post-modernist thinking
but that could be
a strong indicator i started to fall
into post-modernism really hard when i
was like i can i'm creating reality with
my thoughts i
we are you know controlling our reality
in like 2008 nine i really but then
something
i was able to kind of pull out of it i
know that it's not a a deep dark pit
check it out i want to talk about this
link changing thing the different time
that you talked about
yeah this is a huge that's another one
and it was killed by a guy who now works
for the new york times we should
probably make it illegal at some point
another another thing just to go back
real quick
i want to go back to what we're talking
about so is to break down what you're
saying with post-modernism are you
saying people who believe in objective
reality and people who don't
or i think that that's um
an indicator but i actually would
putting it aside
that when we were i was doing the
analysis for the original for the first
trump campaign on what would make
somebody
favorable to support trump and opposed
him a lot of people were trying to do
that too and a lot of them had
sort of these second rate ideas about
you know it's basically uneducated poor
people or in other cases they'd say you
know it's basically racist or some
and somebody actually did a pretty good
study that found that
uh it really did come down to whether or
not you were a
embrace post-modernism which is we get
in trouble with some philosophy types
here but i think it
is basically comes down to if it feels
good do it
and by extension in politics if it feels
good it must be right
yes versus those who utterly reject that
those who have
i would i like to say they possess the
wisdom of the old testament
but there there are many people on the
right who don't like like in in their in
the culture were right who aren't fans
of trump necessarily
but think about the reasons why it's
because he's had three wives he's
very brash he does he has uh he has
exhibit like what they would consider
conspicuous consumption
and i'm not saying those are my
christmas those are the ones that you
might find the people who are
very uncomfortable with him because he
seems so an uncouth brash new yorker
right
you know they've been calling me right
wing for quite some time because i've
continually been defending trump and i
think it's part of the trope of
please stop making me defend trump the
more the media lies
to support the democrats in their
narrative you know i think i think my
uh uh you know true like descent into
the culture war started with
i worked for vice mac i worked for vice
okay i was the founding member of vice
news and what did we do
luke and i uh even after vice we went to
japan and we we went around and we
interviewed people in fukushima
and we got to like experience a natural
disaster it wasn't hyper political or
anything like that
when i worked for vice i went and
covered conflict and crisis in other
countries
it wasn't u.s politics in america but
while i was at fusion
it's where this you know uh one one of
these guys said don't report on the fact
that
the new york times is essentially doing
this extremely unethical behavior
it re what the new york times did when
they changed
links like this resulted in two of the
all-time
top posts on reddit number three and
number five getting deleted
for a violation of the rules i thought
that was a huge story i mean reddit was
one of the biggest social media sites in
the world
the uh two of the highest the biggest
stories ever posted on the site were
deleted because the new york times
was altering stories in secret and he
said don't report that because we do the
same thing
he now works the new york times so i
kind of lost my train of thoughts i
wanted to tell that story
well another aspect that i kind of
wanted to intervene here i've been
waiting to say and whether this is
happening on purpose or an accident we
have to understand that a lot of this
division is also being fueled by big
tech social media algorithms
that promote certain behaviors and
demote other behaviors
so when we look at something that's very
hyperbolic whether it's intentionally or
not done
intentionally we are seeing the worst
elements of our society being presented
to us almost every single day that's
going to have an effect on your psyche
that's going to have an effect on your
brain being programmed when you're at
war
if you can get your enemy to fight
itself it weakens them
at like if they kill kill if you have 5
000 troops and 5 000 troops and they
fight each other and they kill off
2 500 and 2 500 now you only have to
fight 2500 troops or 5 000 troops
that's what they're doing you know what
the easiest way to win a war is to get
your enemy to kill themselves
i guess yeah that's a better i was going
to say get him to stop reproducing at
all or get or like
subject it yeah yeah and if you look at
the fertility numbers and if you look at
the reproduction numbers if you look at
the marriage numbers they're all
down in the decline in the toilets i'm
not saying it's intentionally being done
i'm just saying i think it is i think
that
some for some reason the us constitution
is such a threat to globalization or
or you know global socialism or great
reset can't happen if they're using
post-modernism to inflame people through
social media and it's like blackrock and
state street these global funding
organizations are using this psychosis
and they're like driving us against each
other the pope has come out in support
of the great reset
but the problem with the great reset is
that the united states has a
constitution
they can't do anything about the
constitution i mean i think there's only
one thing that would actually get rid of
the constitution and it's a civil war
so yeah i mean if you're talking about
economies here i think you have another
dichotomy that you're really hitting on
and we're all kind of dancing around
this word that expecting somebody to say
but i don't but
you you have on one hand nationalism
national identity
on the other hand we have something that
can exist at the same space but it has a
tremendous amount of financial
vested interest and energy and power
behind it and that is consumerism
yeah those two things can't exist in the
same place capitalism
well there's a difference in capitalism
i i like consumerism because capitalism
encourages bold thinking revolutionary
change um
creative disruption whereas consumerism
basically
they they just want you to have an
earthworm existence where you consume
excrete consume excrete and die
well the the great reset is opposed to
that
the great reset wants people not to own
anything
well if you don't own anything but you
have to pay everyone forever
you don't you have to pay that rent
forever right you know you can buy
you can buy a cell phone and guess what
it's you don't even own it and it's
gonna be replaced in five years because
you don't stop paying you know when you
go on the world economic forum you see a
lot of generalized bland
language like fairness equal outcome
the public good but essentially when you
deep down and you look into more of
their text
what are they talking about more taxes
more regulations more free trade
agreements like the tpp
which of course benefits the corporate
billionaire wall street banking class
which is in cahoots with also other
foreign governments that they greatly
benefit of
when they subvert other people's
individuals will and sovereignty
that weaselly language you site that is
concealing that that is the biggest
tell of how malignant and uh
and uh malevolent it is you hide it
because our u.s constitution
it's incredibly explicit there's no
doubt there's no weasel words like that
it says exactly what it means that you
know what it means whereas those
buzzwords you're throwing out it's like
oh it sounds good yeah the equality
sustainability the fourth industrial
revolution of outcome that's the
dangerous because you have
quality of opportunity which is great we
all but the quality of outcome
is not great but what were you doing do
you guys know that in the uk they
announced high value individuals will be
exempt from quarantine
i'm not surprised by that it means that
if you're a wealthy and successful
business person you're free to do what
you want travel where you want to go
i bring this up because maybe a lot of
people don't know this
you know the planet has people who have
reached a certain level of wealth
they're completely
they can buy their way out of jail no i
don't want to put it that way they don't
exist in the law in any capacity
so uh one way to put it is they can fly
in a private plane and land at an
airport without without passports
they don't need any of that they can go
where they want when they want for any
reason because they're rich and powerful
and i've uh i've actually met some of
these people and they've told me the
stories about how they do it why they do
it
and once you reach a certain amount of
wealth it doesn't matter
if the united states is imposing a
lockdown it won't affect you at all
in fact the great risk that would
greatly beneficial to you
because well everyone else would lose
ownership of everything you'd have free
access and free rent to do whatever you
want
indefinitely yeah especially individuals
like bill gates that promised to donate
all of their wealth to charity 10 years
ago and now has doubled his wealth
he's also literally on cnbc talking
about how vaccines have been his
greatest ever investment
and how it's a 20 to 1 return for him
personally so so i do believe that when
you mandate them
exactly when when and this is again bill
gates the person pushing for a lot of
these policies and also pushing for
the global reset a part of the other you
know big players here that are calling
for this and are saying
we got to do this essentially they do
care because it does essentially work
out for them in certain ways
like the bill gates you know very very
powerful interests
the world economic forum has publicly
stated they want a great reset
the new york they published this the new
york times then wrote a story saying it
was a baseless conspiracy theory
we're past that point now where we're
seeing articles from like the guardian
where it says
the great reset is being maligned so now
they're like openly just being like of
course we're going to do this
of course it's our opportunity the
constitution constitution's in the way
so they're going to own stuff that we're
going to rent from them no
no no no we have a constitution so it's
been very very difficult i mean you look
at the republican states and they've
said no you look at pennsylvania and
michigan
and the supreme courts i think of even
their states have struck down their
attempts at locking down
this is what they want is a world where
no one owns anything they don't mean
everyone owns nothing they mean that
most
people own nothing and they're going to
own it and we're going to rent it from
them and they're all going to do it in
the name of equality and sustainability
by pushing again more controls more
regulations so independent people
can't start their own businesses can't
have their own businesses all the
competition against them and their
buddies
is totally wiped out and they call this
redefining capitalism have you have you
seen the video of the woman in
california from the pineapple was a
pineapple hill
where she she's uh she's the hollywood
has set up these picnic tables and yeah
benches and then she can't have hers
what did she say she said everything i
own
is being taken from me yes
the rich people are doing fine i mean
bezos bill gates these these wealthy
individuals have made so much money
uh in the pa in the past year the the
amazon stock has skyrocketed why because
small businesses shut down and big box
stores are allowed to to expand
so i feel like we're heading towards
idiocracy where we're gonna have one
store
you know you know have you guys seen
that movie where it's just one big
costco
that's gonna be amazon when you want
goods you're not gonna go to the store
you're gonna you're gonna go to amazon
it's
only the only way to get stuff well
let's talk about the monopoly of
facebook and how they're looking at
breaking up
the monopoly talking about big giant
corporations
facebook is i mean facebook is is in a
different vein
um they're it's it's i don't know
specifically when we look at that
uh article when you say you won't own
nothing it was from an article from the
you know world economic forum about
their vision of 2030
and it specifically said you will own
nothing you will have no privacy but you
will be happy
in in other words human slavery is going
to be back they're not wrong and our
friends are going to benefit from it
ignorance is bliss to some people i
would argue against that and so many
different instances no
ignorance is blessed it's it's true
right so i'll put it this way
if there was a a space colony
floating in orbit where everyone who
lived there was you know advanced a
thousand years of technology and
they were immortal and could fly and
could teleport you would wish and long
for that if you knew it existed
you don't know exist so you can only be
as happy as you are in your in the
moment i'm not i'm not advocating for
ignorance no
but what they're saying is if we can
take the idea of freedom and liberty
away from the individual
then they won't long for what they don't
know exists
so they want to take away ownership so
that you're happy and complacent in the
future not even thinking
it can exist i i i think humans the
human spirit and human will naturally
goes towards
liberty towards freedom towards
sovereignty what did harriet tubman say
i have created many slaves and i would
have freed many more if only they knew
they were slaves
that's true uh there are instances where
you could look at the pessimistic aspect
of it
and there are aspects of it that you can
look at the aspects that
propelled humanity and progressed us
forward in positive ways and that road
is always the road of
freedom though the road of winds if you
look at
if you look at civilizations and how
they stifled they stifled when there is
a lack of freedom there's a lack of
communication there's a lack of
dialogue and now us getting this
dialogue taken away from us is the first
warning shot that i think people would
really need to pay attention to because
once we
can't even talk to each other once we
can't even be able to listen to what's
really going on there
we've already lost you know when i grew
up at that step i used to listen to a
lot of punk rock
and there's a song by a band called
anti-flag called underground network
and one of the lines is underground
network alternative communication i
think it's really funny because that was
a very left thing back in the day
and now we are at the point where it is
the right
youtube has explicitly stated if you
believe
in specific things about this election
that would be beneficial to trump
they will remove your content from the
platform an overt
and outright benefit to joe biden just
like censoring the story of his family
being crooked
and uh and he first looked joe biden
facilitated his son's trip to china to
negotiate one of these deals
they got what was it a five million
dollar uh forgivable interest-free loan
they called it
billions i mean forgivable it means you
don't got to pay it back
okay so it's a gift it was just a bra no
no no
no you can't accuse them of taking a
bribe that would be that would be a
defamation is there any punishment to
not giving back a forgivable loan
so a forgivable loan could be like hey
ian i'll lend you a hundred dollars
and if you um you know bring in the the
amazon boxes when they come i'll forgive
the loan
so there's a condition that can be met
that makes it so you don't owe me any
money any money oh and it can be any
condition
tony babiolinsky said he told him not to
take the money and they got rich behind
his back
and he thinks they're compromised the
media suppressed this
and just like youtube is now telling us
they're going to suppress information
i'm i'm really interested to what
happens at the out
the result of some of these lawsuits
pertaining to fraud if something
favorable happens for trump and a judge
asserts that what youtube said you can't
say is in fact true
and when i asked him about this they had
no answer they were like you can't make
these claims and i said what happens if
a judge agrees
and says it's true well you know our
policy says
i have a question for you does does your
policy prohibit you from questioning uh
kennedy's
victory against nixon really yes so
illinois you can't discuss the fact so
that's actually
a historical uh uh conspiracy i guess
like
there are accusations that uh the mafia
helps jfk i guess is that
what the story was well there's a lot of
people like anything that moves
far enough back in time you start to get
experts who re-review things and find
oh maybe this is the case or you know i
don't know if there's only
a homosexual or something reviewing it
and saying well maybe
you know academic research but asserting
it as fact like so i think
a researcher would say we found evidence
that suggest as such
and and i guess that's fine let's assert
this is awesome then i've never heard
anything about this can you
talk about this so i think there's only
one president who lost florida and ohio
uh to not get elected just there's two
presidents
i could be wrong about this uh but i'm
pretty sure
richard nixon in his uh uh race with uh
in
the election with kennedy law nixon won
ohio and florida but lost the election
and donald trump donald trump won uh
ohio and florida but lost the election
what what year was this the nixon
60 was the 66. no it was 16. 60 flat
16 16. it was end of eisenhower those
are cool debates because
nixon was all sweaty i mean he just
looked like
some of the first debates but um what
what youtube said is you can't question
the outcome of a historical election and
um specifically
if you said that there was widespread
fraud that resulted in
you know and this is the second criteria
i'm being trying to avoid the algorithm
just because it's hypothetical
uh that resulted in kennedy you know
winning
or nixon losing that would also be a ban
ebola fence what about in another
country
i wonder yeah i was just thinking that
does this apply to north korea
right during the north korean elections
can you not detest the north carolina
right
i think i think youtube's saying
historical election criteria is just
a manipulation where they could give
themselves an excuse what is historic
election every election is historical
we we number the presidents and have
lists of them three books yeah they go
in history books they own the
encyclopedias
you know so that's a ridiculous bar
i think you should youtube should build
like a zone where we can talk about this
stuff
no conspiracy zone and then just don't
monetize it
isn't it kind of crazy though that they
want to do something right
but the language they came up for was
just so pants on head
stupid isn't that surprising would you
have expected them to come up with
something a little bit more bulletproof
or
something you couldn't just pick apart
so easily i think the issue
they came up with is oh these are the
rules so
yeah yeah they're trying to find a way
and a right time to stop
people from talking what they're doing
is over
the way described it is there's uh run a
large island with sheer cliffs on every
side
and over time the cliffs have been
eroding and it's all
you know from the right for the most
part well it's also a chilling effect
which is also important here because i
remember when the hunter biden story
came out i had to make a decision i'm
like
you know big news organizations are
getting cancelled for this if i mention
this i could get cancelled
do i even talk about this and i have to
say yes but i could imagine there's
other people in my position
who would say no i'm not going to talk
about it and i think i want to play it
safe
and some of them did get banned tons of
the the the videos
uh tons of i think 8 000 channels this
year were deleted
just outright with no strikes just nuked
some of them because they were
questioning
uh covet guidelines and restrictions so
just gone
some of them with medical doctors and
professionals with literal
phds and pathologies looking at
scientific data and breaking it down so
people understand it were banned
because they went against the procedures
and protocols of
the world health organization which
keeps flip-flopping and changing their
official stance
i think i like youtube better now than
2008 because we can stream live on it
if they didn't have the tech in 2008 but
in 2008 you guys check out
warren 25 go look at old warren 25
videos
people's you could crazy scream anything
at the camera as long as it wasn't like
elite explicitly illegal you know
youtube has become
uh for all intents and purposes like you
know netflix
in 2013 i i i i know people who work at
google in 2013 i had a
meeting with some google employees and
they said
netflix is our biggest competition and i
said what are you talking about
i was like you represent you know
individuals who can make channels and
they talk to their friends and their
families
and it creates a decentralized network
from the smallest audience to the
biggest
what makes you think you're competing
with netflix and it was simple they said
you know look at vice when vice.com came
on the scene
they were getting tens of millions of
views on their documentaries
when netflix went digital and started
allowing streaming
youtube lost that viewership but more
importantly vice documentaries dropped
by like 80 percent in viewership
millennials were going on youtube to
look for content to watch to stream
so netflix launched a high quality you
know hollywood production you know of
streaming content
and then people chose that over youtube
so youtube's ever since then been
prioritizing
disney channel ask type content well
they changed their algorithm to promote
long format videos
rather than short format videos because
because if you remember back in the day
it was two minute videos four minute
videos that were the most popular
now it's ten minutes plus and you see
because they hurt you if you don't yes
exactly so that's another question
that's that's i should say they only
promote
10 minutes the algorithm doesn't promote
you if you don't
follow these like and there's a and
there's a ton of them that you have to
follow which is absolutely crazy and
insane one i wonder if netflix will
start allowing you to flip on a camera
and stream live and get ad revenue
because it's the other way around
youtube's gonna eventually take that
right away
uh you think they'll get rid of it i
think it's youtube's biggest value is
being able to flip a camera on and get
paid
no you can't get paid you could add
revenue luke's not in the partner
program well not right now yeah i got
kicked out he can't get back in
it's been 10 months now well then they
should review it do you know do you want
to know why the only reason
uh well i don't get too specific but i
can get a youtube channel uh monetize
rather rather quickly
i have to meet the criteria of like i
think it's like what four thousand hours
and like a thousand subs
yes and then i have to actually just
call google
and be like hey i've got a channel can
you guys monetize it and they'll say
we'll get back to you so did you
say you thought youtube was gonna get
rid of that feature
youtube has already gotten rid of the
open partner program oh yeah it's not
open anymore but i wonder if
facebook's doing it right i think we're
going to come to a point
in a year or two where youtube disables
user uploads without
certification so in order to upload
you'll have to submit your id
and then you wait a month and then
they'll approve you and then you can
publish to youtube
and then to get into the partner program
it's going to be you know they have to
wait a year
they're probably going to put like you
have to be a user uploading content for
six months
so we can review your content submit
your id and verify your identity
give us your tax forms six months later
brain chip
vaccination certification you don't want
to make the barrier link so we can scan
your
entry too hard because it'll be too easy
for other people to go on their own
website and
stream live and take like monthly
subscriptions that's almost here
why is it that i mean i think you're
right um one thing that keeps youtube
dominant is the partner program
so long as people know if i go on
youtube i make money
if i go on mines.com i don't get crypto
yeah well but they turned their back on
what made them great
what made youtube great was individuals
coming together and just
without the corporate squeegee clean pr
corporate approved talking points just
were natural just were real
it was organic it was something to
really watch and to be surprised by
and to really kind of progress yourself
and to really expand your mind with all
these different opinions and different
talking points
and now it's just like here's disney
plus and all this other nonsense and
crap that you see everywhere
regurgitated in the same format and way
i think steven crowder is so i i though
i described it as the
the cliffs are eroding so two years ago
there was the far right edge of the
cliff and the far left edge of the cliff
and the farther edge of the cliff
actually did face some erosion they were
actually suppressing some content
and they did ban a bunch of creators
recently there was actually a trend
well this happened on twitter so in the
general free speech conversation a bunch
of leftists now got banned
and like you know i said i said they're
useful what did they say that got them
banned
nothing they were just one day just gone
so you know i think it was their
usefulness to the establishment had
had is gone inspired so now while they
were allowed to stay on the platform and
advocate for certain things once the
election happened
they got rid of him but uh anyway the
the the right end of the cliff has been
eroding for years
i was actually interviewed by oliver
darcy of cnn about the troubling nature
of
banning the alt-right from social media
and i just
my point was they can have you know
deplorable opinions so long as they're
not breaking the law calling for
violence inciting violence or advocating
for you know horrific you know crimes
then they're about to have their
opinions and i actually you know oliver
darcy of all people so
they get banned now we're at the point
where if you question the election in a
certain way you'll get banned
well i think stephen crowder is the one
who's now standing with his tippy toes
to the edge of the cliff as it's eroding
because
i mean he's absolutely going after these
stories and interviewing people and
challenging them
and and and then we're standing right
behind them i mean especially having you
on the show matt
yeah these conversations yeah welcome
well
you know we're gonna have uh probably
our biggest show don't please don't say
anything anybody because i'm gonna
i think we're gonna have one of our
biggest shows tomorrow and i'm really
poking the bear
so uh i have my limits i i've said it
over and over again if i get banned
i'm gonna go skateboarding i'm gonna go
fishing down by the river and
and you know there's only so much you
can do as the cliffs are eroding before
you before you say i will not retreat
i will not you can redivert lava flow
from volcanoes to build more land mass
if you need more cliff space sure i
don't know how the edges of the land
were eroding let's build more edge
do you not have a backup platform plan
where you would go if something happened
to you on this
youtube owns the space they they they
own all the ad they've monopolized the
ad revenue
and everything so what we're doing right
now is we're building a proprietary
website
so that users can subscribe as members
and then get
you know so a more traditional business
model on top of what we have because i
think
i think we're going to do uh one of our
biggest shows probably our biggest show
tomorrow
and uh i don't think it i think it could
result in
a first step towards possibly getting
banned because i'm just you know because
i
i think it's possible i think mines is
really great i co-founded mines
um a decade ago but we can't we don't
have video streaming yet
and there's no fiat you can't get paid
with fiat yet either it's just crypto
youtube is subsidized by google youtube
loses money and always has
and the reason this happens is that
youtube
costs ridiculous are you familiar with
how bandwidth expense
expensive bandwidth is sure so right now
we have uh 58
547 concurrent viewers the most we had
was around i think we hit like 60
61. 61 000 that means for
the what what do we got we got like
ninety eight thousand
three megabits per second up means
youtube is sending out
three megabits out time well they
probably compress it so
maybe a megabit times sixty one thousand
fifty eight thousand
that's that's free for me i'm not
spending any money
on broadcasting all this data to people
youtube loses money but
google monopolized the space so what
they're doing is by subsidizing youtube
they make sure no competitor can emerge
why look i my videos automatically sync
to bitshoot
it's a great safety net because i've had
videos taken down and then people can
still watch them
but i can't make ad revenue on bitshoot
which means if i focus on that or even
facebook
yeah what's up with facebook can you get
ad revenue on facebook now uh so
facebook rev
actually it's not that bad um nowhere
near as good as youtube
but it's not worth pursuing because
listen when i first started doing
youtube this was back in 2011 or
whatever
and i was getting like five bucks a week
doing a video every day and i said
if i can't survive on this i'm going to
run out of money and then i can't do
anything ever again
but once you get enough money to invest
in yourself to start the business get
the ball rolling and then make just
enough
you're good youtube allows you to
actually live
i'm not talking about even living well
like youtube is the only platform where
you can actually pay your rent and keep
working buy manchester used it for me
you know when you when you get to a
certain point you've got several gold
you know youtube awards and you have a
certain level of viewership you make a
lot of money
there's no way that i could make
anywhere near as much money on any any
other platform
so it's not it's it's also like this
what people need to realize when they're
like tim you've got to go to an
alternative platform
if if if youtube bans me i have to fire
everybody
that's it everyone's fired i can't
there's there's no money to pay bills
so this you know youtube controls they
own it
that's why the big move right now is we
we are uh working on putting together a
proprietary website
so that people can become members and
get access to premium content the idea
is going to be that we'll we'll do a
show
when we wrap up the live show we do a
bonus 10 minute segment for members only
and and
you know give a value permission to
everyone you know so people who are
already members
um we'll want to figure it out because i
want to make sure everybody gets access
to it's not super easy
but um maybe using the membership thing
on youtube and then also having our
website
if youtube bans us then we'll have
paying subscribers
but then there's a whole marketing
aspect to it user growth and things like
that becomes very difficult and stagnant
my bigger concern is you know we've this
this is a company i have people who are
you know staff employees and if i get
banned
then i can't have no money to pay
anything maybe youtube's the uh monopoly
then
yes well it's alphabet it's google it's
alphabet they're nailing facebook with a
monopoly charge which i think is maybe
foolish because if i've seen this before
the show if zuckerberg has access to all
that code and then he has to give up
whatsapp and what's his other company uh
instagram instagram and what's at the
top
they'll just hold them they'll rewrite
that software function
for facebook prime and then right so
it's
it's you know they tried that with
snapchat when they did i thought it was
called facebook
like disappearing messages and it didn't
work stories
i forgot it was called if facebook
created a snapchat clone
did take off so they they tried buying
they tried buying snapchat they
snapchat wouldn't sell they tried
cloning it didn't work so it could be if
instagram is broken off from facebook
they won't be able to recreate what
instagram is you know because instagram
has the community
so they'll have like a do not compete
clause along with the
the sioux without with the breakup i
don't know um
i just think that conservatives aren't
going to go away
you can ban stephen crowder and i don't
think conservatives are going to be like
well i guess you know that's it no
they're going to
i think parlor might be the biggest
indicator
of uh uh just they can't get rid of this
faction
you know youtube twitter the democrats
would love to absolutely erase
the populist right and and the general
right from existence
in terms of public communication they
can't and
and you know they can't control parlor
now too many prominent individuals are
on it
and i'm surprised donald trump hasn't
been using it he absolutely needs to go
on there
if donald trump only made posts from
parlor at this point on
the media would do nothing but say
parlor parlor parlor there's another one
called rumble
i keep hearing about the video video
hosting library is another one where you
can get crypto parlor kyc
people going on there and then i also
think trump might lose his twitter
account soon as well
i don't think so maybe maybe um
they've been saying that the moment
trump uh is you know biden's inaugurated
trump loses his protections
and then he's got a bunch of tweets
already they'll probably just get rid of
like they'll just ban him
but um i think it was michael maus who
said this they're not gonna get rid of
him because he's
too much of a prominent character that
generates you know traffic for the site
before trump became really active
twitter was dying the mainstream media
was dying
yes yeah ratings were collapsing i got
this feeling like we should put
media presence on every site on rumble
library mines facebook instagram but
it's like i don't want to
i we should just have our own site our
own
thing that we own i don't like the isp
you know there used to be a little bit
of technology that made that very easy
but it seems to have faded away do any
of you remember something called rss
yeah cause rs look if you think about it
if everybody had their own social media
rss feed then nobody would essentially
control it it'll be
sort of networking you just subscribe to
the rss feed that you want and
it generates what you know what would
have been your feedback in the day but
you know i guess your timeline we call
it now
and it'll all be completely independent
so that's that's how podcasts work
yeah so uh for people who aren't
familiar i don't upload to itunes
i upload to a server which produces an
rss link
and then all the podcast directories
just have the link you know right
but back in the day this business to
business rss feeds for podcasts and
other things like that right because the
the services need something wrong
but back in the day a person would click
the link to
yeah i want to share this you know have
this rss feed and actually
google cancelled was it reader was their
big rss tools
they took it away and and you know it
just became so far out of mainstream but
it used to be
a great thing this you'd have news
groups and it was all it wasn't
centrally controlled like it is now
yeah this idea of a big central power
controlling your algorithm
controlling your timeline is absolutely
insane it's one of the reasons i hear
some people on on the internet say
the revolution won't be in your timeline
or in your news feed but
there's also another aspect to this that
we have to understand that
there have even been psychological
studies showing how the algorithms could
manipulate people's emotions and
feelings and
certain algorithms could make you feel
sad facebook admitted they were doing
experiments on people exactly to and
unsuspecting individuals
not people who wanted to participate but
people who they were looking into and
and data feeding harvesting
so much information about them that it's
absolutely scary because
as we were talking about i don't know if
we were talking about this on the show
facebook knows when you go
to take a dump to that level of
certainty
and they know so much about you and they
data harvest
every little aspect of you and now
they're toying and they probably already
figured this out
how to manipulate people's emotions and
feelings and
to make you feel scared sad and
horrified or
happy productive good and then when you
look at the mental health crisis in
america it really makes you wonder
what's going on
the only thing that gets rid of the
constitution is a civil war
well that's one thing that might get rid
of the constitution but i'm sure there
could be other biden presidency i don't
know
i mean the supreme court though think
about it for a long time
despite the constitution having a second
amendment it was just completely ignored
so i just getting enough judges who
interpret the constitution or
they start inventing rights they find
penumbras um legislative
uh ordering judicially things that
aren't remotely in the constitution just
invent it so
but you know the solution this whole
social media thing all this centralized
control you know what
the answer this is right we all just
have to get our ham radio operators
licenses
right that's the answer that's that's
where the revolution has to happen i
bought well a few months ago
and i think there's i could be wrong
with internet over him there's a way to
get like
like text over him or geo location like
you know all kinds of ways to yeah so we
could create we could create a ham
twitter
yeah we could yeah we gotta go super
chats
we're going long you ready for for super
chats they're gonna ask a bunch of
questions you probably can't answer i
don't know what a super chat is
use your comments okay cool questions
and comments uh
i'm not gonna read this one okay i'm
gonna read it maybe i don't know
i shouldn't read it i've got a thick
skin and i've had no no no it's just
dangerous
read who it's from so they know what
nine unbuffed said just say when mr
president
gwyneth kobach says tim thanks uh thanks
tim for your show my little kids love
having your show on as they fall asleep
so you must be doing something right
keep it milk toast that's interesting
protective services i used to listen to
uh love line when i was in
oh i love that show young teenager with
like adam carol and dr drew yeah
mine was beavers and butthead well yeah
i mean i watched that too but like you
turn the radio on and you hear adam
corolla yeah nine o'clock go to sleep
joel jamal says just broke this on my
channel here in australia we had a
vaccine developed back in april this
year by university in the state of sa
it received a 7 out of 7 international
peer review rating
they developed it so quickly because
they just continued their work on the
sar
the sars virus oh interesting so uh
did you hear about the bell's palsy
and the allergic reactions from the
fizer vaccine yes
so this is an important psa for
everybody just you know while we have
the vaccine as the fda today approved
the pfizer vaccine to be used in the
united states in a vote for
17 that said yes four said no and one
person abstained
the uk has said and this is a legitimate
warning i can't believe people are
accusing me of being anti-vex for
telling you what the what the health
administ
nhs is telling people um if you have a
severe
allergic reaction you you should not be
getting this vaccine
because several people have developed i
believe it's 0.685 percent developed
anaphylax anaphylactic reaction meaning
your eyes swell your throat could swell
and uh two nurses in the uk needed a
shot of epinephrine an autoinjector
so the uk has said it can only be
administered in a place where
resuscitation measures are are possible
yeah
so this is like if you're going to go
get it make sure you're getting it at a
proper facility
and and if you have allergies the uk
we're not uk citizens so take your
advice from your doctor in the us but
this is something that's happening
that's
68 people out of a thousand are having
severe anal anaphylactic shock
yeah and i think they said uh you have
one in 200 chance of severe severe side
effects
not trying to freaking be on anything
just trying to make sure people get the
proper advice and this is what the news
organizations have have issued so this
is not
like this is the guardian you know
saying this stuff they want everyone to
know
yeah if you look at the side effects
list it's a little daunting sorry go
ahead what could possibly cause
anaphylactic because the way
anaphylactic shock works is it's
it's the second exposure to the
triggering element
well so it could be like uh is there's
got to be something in there that you've
exp
yeah experienced before to get the
yellow flagship maybe they had code it
could be a preservative that's in
serials it could be a preservative maybe
they had it coveted previously
it could be anything they don't know the
way the vaccine works i watched it
i watched a two-minute documentary on it
isn't it two minutes
there's like 19 proteins in the the
virus i think and it
encodes for the one of the 18 or 19 the
outer layer
that makes the virus connect and then
your body thinks it has that protein and
then when it sees it it's ready for it
so if you already had that in your
system and then you get it a second but
the the vaccine your body thinks you're
getting it again
maybe it could go it's a shock it's
common in medications
that there could be an analytic reaction
that's why they're not freaking out
they're just saying if you have
allergies this is actually typical for
vaccines you should you know
wait did you get the specifics what vac
what allergies or is it like they don't
take it if you're allergic to it just
if you have if you have severe allergies
don't you see the warnings now on on a
lot of pharmaceutical commercials do not
take
exospirin if you're allergic to it yeah
like what kind of stupid
suggestion all right let's read some
more super chats
einar says to matt please make a dead
man switch for your info
and have it guaranteed to go public in
february tim should be able to help you
make one
that's not a terrible idea
that's not a bad suggestion uh like i
mean it's not a hard thing to do you i
mean it's i wouldn't even
say necessarily say dead man switch you
should set it up so that it's scheduled
to release after the resolution or
whatever
you know yeah but even more than that is
that it doesn't need a tendency switch
because
almost all of this is it could be
reproduced by anybody it's not only that
aren't there many many individuals who
already have copies of all of it anyway
that is true but it's not necessarily a
dead man's switch right
right i've never had one before so i
think it's time it would be cool
yeah just be able to say by the way if
something happens to me
that'd be awesome yeah all right let's
see
i'm not your buddy guy says why do we
chalk up all voting fraud and propriety
to always being too small to change
elections
if a spouse cheats does it get worse or
stay the same over time
when someone steals it get worse over
time so why would voting be any
different
this is one of the problems i think we
have with the court system they say like
you need injury
in fact in order to file a suit but then
so that means that the impropriety can
continue
until someone receives damages enough so
a better example would be defamation
when when i've had news outlets and you
know activists
outright lie and make things up every
you can't do anything about it because
the lawyers will ask you what's your
damages
and it's like okay well this is caused a
threat to my advertisers okay how many
advertisers have you lost
i'm like are you serious i have to wait
until my business collapses before i can
do anything about this
they'll just keep doing it exactly it's
like the opposite of the broken window
theory the giuliani version not the
economics version is that if if you
tolerate a
neighborhood with broken windows you
just tolerate because it's such a
minimal
infraction to the law no big deal or you
tolerate uh
jaywalkers well then you just encourage
greater and greater crimes but if you
crack down on the smaller crimes it will
abate
so in the same way if you crack down
really hard on defamation
regardless of economic damages or
instances of people casting illegal
ballots
uh it will be it will counter the more
substantial or
prevent it from growing here's the most
important question corey williams says
what happened to your hand
trump 2020 use the money well so uh i
was skating
earlier today and i was hanging out you
know
with adam we were skating and i had just
done a 5-0 on the ledge and five votes
it feels under familiar it's a very
basic easy grind
and adam was like yeah i'm like clapping
and i was like oh dude that's nothing
that's like a basic trick
and he was like dude take the take the
the you know the compliment
and i was like i'll do a nollie five-o
shove it first try and so this is a
little bit more complicated
and it is something i can typically do
first try but here i was all arrogant
like you think that was cool
watch me do this and then i went flipped
over slammed on my hand and i actually
thought i broke it but it's just
sprained
so uh the moral of the story is this is
something every skateboarder
is supposed to know you don't screw
around and you respect the trick when
you're always doing it because you
always get hurt whenever you're like
just goofing off
and so here i am like i'm just going to
do this and i'm you know i wasn't
thinking and i slipped and
there you go but it's mostly fine also
learn how to take a compliment tim
i know you're great at your job well it
was it was it was more of like a hokey
joke where like adam was laughing and
i'm like oh yeah i was like
check this out you know what i mean and
then i fell cause like
there you go not necessarily see the new
setup though we're building a bar it's
going to be called the grind bar
dude skateboarders it's an actual bar
you can drink off and you can grind on
it so
we have uh the the skateboard
construction company that built
everything left this really long
you know bar i think i forgot i forgot
what it's made of but uh
it's great for grinding on skateboard
grinding on a skateboard is when you
jump up and you know the metal part of
the of the
the trucks the wheel part slides across
the metal and so we're making a bar
and the front of the bar is going to be
grindable sort of called the grind bar
yeah but it's an actual bar you can like
sit yes we're actually going to have
drinks and you know people are going to
work as a workshop
we've got a 3d printer and stuff yeah
it's going to be really really these are
incoming
all right let's see we gotta this one
just came in so i'll read this one now
logan matthew says
please look up the obdm podcast on
youtube the host midnight mike
his birthday is tomorrow and he has put
in over 15 years building his community
as a gift i thought i could try to get
you both in touch
the world would be better place with
both uh with you both had a conversation
all right midnight mike and the obdm
podcast
ready to rumble says tim constantly
kissing youtube's arse
i mean well i would disagree with that i
mean you know
wait till you see what happens tomorrow
yeah one of the reasons like i mean
you have me on which is like pretty i
mean you're taking a principal stand
which is commendable and
respect for that youtube hates luke yes
i i have
i had many encounters with eric schmidt
that were pretty interesting
uh at bilderberg to say the least so i
you know i appreciate what you're doing
you're making a stand
and that's commendable and they don't um
yeah don't don't ever
hesitate to pick up the enemy's
ammunition off the ground
it's figurative figuratively yes there's
an old there's an old story of um
i can't remember it maybe people in the
chat will know the story but there was
like i think it was like britain and
france or whatever fighting
and what one side did was they made it
so their arrow notches
were really really thin and small that
way
their bows which use a thinner string
could fire back the enemy's arrows
had a large notch but the enemy couldn't
fire back their arrows with that has
small notch
get it it's clever huh yep this is a
good metaphor for what you're doing
right now
right don't let your enemy use your mo
against you and be prepared to counter
what they're using you know all right
let's see
waffles sensei says tim you can still
talk about everything you want on
youtube without getting censored
you just have to say the opposite thing
with really heavy sarcasm
and then you will know it's if it's the
algorithm or people watching
well that's the joke we were talking
about earlier like if we were uh
if i said something uh i'm gonna avoid
using the full joke because i'd
probably get banned but if i went of
course
that's why joe biden won
just very okay for those other listing i
just did a really heavy and obvious wink
at the camera
i think they could hear it it was so
heavy yeah yeah so it's like if you just
you know if you were like i absolutely
think joe biden legitimately won he's
the greatest president of all time
they'll build facial recognition to tell
but i wonder if in the future when the
ai
comes and tries and fights us if sarcasm
is going to be how we win
well i think what would happen is we'll
be sitting here talking and then as soon
as you cross the line the gigantic mech
robot will walk up the stairs and go
like
drop the sarcasm go back okay okay and
they're like
the gun's going no no no okay we're done
we're done we're done
and then it walks away no i think there
was an outer limits episode where they
had this thing called the stream
where there were like modems all over
the place and they was hooked in their
brains
and it always knew it was like
essentially sentient
so it'll be more like that you know will
be neural linkedin
you know i'll tell you this a lot you're
familiar with neurolink right
elon musk's you know everyone's good you
know i think luke you're not going to
get it right
i think that's it are you going to get
it matt you i am not intending to
surrender any of that
i i was uh uh i i could be
you know remembering this wrong because
it's been like 20 years but my grandpa
was talking to me about social security
numbers and how he thought it was insane
that we got registered with a number
with the government
and how crazy was that but for me he was
like you don't care because
it's it's always existed it's normal for
your life
but he's like this is nuts i think he
was when did the social security number
thing happen it was like the 1930s 30s
what was fdr
so yeah yeah so my grandpa was like i
think he was
a kid or a teenager there was a big
pushback against that yeah i thought it
was insane like i got to get a number
are you nuts in fact the law was
specified it was printed
on the social security card itself that
it is not allowed to be used as
identification
wow yeah oh have time the old social
security cards have that now that
now it's these numbers and these track
these are tracking device numbers
with your personal phone the idea of the
phone yeah the number you can change
your phone number but
so i think in in 50 years everyone's
going to be neural linked and they're
going to be like who wouldn't want the
neural link wait one second i'm getting
a message from our suite overlord
you know they can track you with this
thing yeah
that's what they're gonna say to each
other you know the neural link you can
get tracked with an erlang and they'll
be like yeah i know
it's gonna be like people are gonna get
installed via um the home assistant
neural link plugin
and they're gonna be sitting there and
they're gonna go and they're gonna say
like
neural link when was x y and z and
they're like you have one of those you
you have the
assistant in your brain you're not
spying on you right whatever
i want to say so many things about butt
toxins but this is a family-friendly
show we can't get into that
we're seeing the same thing i think
we'll see that evolution with um
automobiles remember
how hard a fight it was to allow ai
driven cars on the road
like you know california or they
wouldn't allow it or
certain restrictions very hard and it's
kind of edging that way and i i believe
that our
our children's generation are probably
going to grow up with the other way
around so
you need a special license if you can
get one at all to drive your own car
because you're only going to be allowed
to be in an ar driven car i don't know
why i'm thinking about michael hastings
now but i am
you know yeah yeah for those that aren't
familiar
i'll give you the quick gist one day he
went to his neighbor he's a journalist
he was who's he's working on a story
about
um top military officials
and intelligence a specific guy uh
general's name
so he went to his neighbor's house and
he said that he had seen someone
fiddling around under his car and wanted
to borrow his neighbor's car and his
neighbor said no you can't use my car
and then i think it was what that night
his car was going 70 miles an hour down
was at wilshire boulevard in la and hit
a tree and exploded
it was like two in the morning and i
think it was after he left the bar so
there was some
ideas that maybe he was wasted and like
depressed but
that was usually if the cia is going to
have you killed they try and make you
look depressed and that it was a suicide
joe biggs
uh his friend i mean a lot of people
were friends with him he was
i think he was more of like a uh in like
the glenn greenwald kind of circles yes
so ai cars careful is what you're saying
all right let's do some more super chats
naomi mathias says when tim poole and
rush limbaugh say the same thing has to
be political singularity
i could be wrong um i could be
absolutely wrong about all the civil war
stuff
the only thing i can say is for all i
know right now the lawsuit gets booted
and then all of these republican states
go oh well and then it's over right
sure maybe or maybe
we've just been seeing constant
escalation the entire time and now
we have the most extreme escalation
states lining up against each other
but for real it could just stop i have
no idea i can't predict the future who
knows what's gonna happen
so one super chat they just said uh
like countries have gone a civil war for
way less than what we're seeing now yeah
but
i have to imagine it's not going to be
like right now what happens the supreme
court
i imagine they're not going to take it i
really do um because i've read a lot
from
people on the left and the right why
supreme court would not want to take
this
and they might not i don't think
anything would happen right away
but what happens in you know next year
when you know joe biden says he's gonna
he's gonna order a 100 day like mass
mandate nationwide or whatever
people are going to say no they're
absolutely going to say no and then
that's
that's a really dangerous precedent
because it precipitates a la
loss of confidence in government and
government is nothing but the confidence
of the people
the commander says trump should split
with the reps and make a trump party
from there he should take over the
alliance party which is centrist made of
15 smaller populist centrist parties
and appeal to central democrats and libs
tim should like alliance oh
check it out all right let's see
rita hoe says ccp has moved forward with
their agenda
and start to pave the path for kamala to
take over by investigating hunter biden
well what people are saying now about
the stories coming out
that hunter biden is compromise and joe
is that it's uh it's not an accident
they need a reason to remove joe biden
and make kamala has the president now so
now they're going to be like oh no
jose whatever but i think that's a bit
too conspiratorial i think these the i
think what really happened is nobody
wanted to do the story like you were
saying because they didn't want to be
the journalist to hurt joe biden
and now the election's over they don't
care and they're going to cover the
story because they get some clicks
so based says four democrat senators
sent a letter to youtube on november
24th suggesting censorship of election
fraud speech on youtube
government censoring through private
business yup absolutely
marcus pinson says earlier this week ian
said he wanted to be able to make his
own ammo from scratch
i've been working on something for a few
years that i think is right up his alley
i messaged him on instagram tell him to
hit me up i promise it's really cool i
got a lot of response about that
one person said hey you said you wanted
to make ammo i got some advice for you
don't bother
uh it's almost impossible to find primer
someone else suggested that if we can
get the primer they'll make it for us
um it seems like a huge and really
complex
only four factories make primer in the
united states and they're all fulfilling
government contracts
and you need like explosives license to
make manufacture powder
it's extremely difficult you need a huge
investment and there's a big process and
you barely get a return on your
investment
all things said i haven't responded to
anyone about it because i was a little
overwhelmed and
maybe it's just something we shouldn't
focus on right now i don't know
see brokerages uh brokages over hokages
i said brokerages until i saw the last
word and then i understood the reference
says tim you always talk about the
spanish civil war when the scenario
would be more closer to the russian
civil war
where the bolsheviks own the cities and
the whites were more in the rural areas
and passed the euros
uh perhaps it's because i watched a
documentary in the spanish civil war
uh two years ago and at the time there
was like parallels and people were
talking about it quite a bit
but uh since then i've only you know
i've not watched but i'll i'll
i'll read up and watch something about
the russian civil war as well a lot of
people are comparing it to the chinese
cultural revolution
to what's happening now as well yes yeah
more than the the russians were at
world war one which we're not in right
now and they had a monarchy which we
don't have
but the chinese were like the cultural
revolut
yeah into that or maybe closer to
cambodia camarous
that's true yes nice yeah
man uh let's see md adrian says
unspoken problem in the u.s is that we
are not really a people at this time
they have broken us until we have no
common language history ethnic
background culture and now no rule of
law
what is left to hold us together the
constitution i suppose but a lot of
people the new republic published an
article saying it's time to abolish the
constitution
you know another country found itself
barely a country found itself in this
position historically
are you familiar with the history of
singapore no well it
basically singapore was ethnically
divided linguistically religiously
divided it was so
so the crime was so bad that malaysia
actually kicked it out of the country it
said you're no longer part of us because
it's this island
on the south of their island chain
completely got rid of them
and what pulled it back together was uh
they had a revolutionary leader
lee kuan yew who imposed strict
nationalism he imposed
a national language which happened to be
english which didn't make anybody happy
because it wasn't their native tongue
he imposed strict rules anti-corruption
etc and that was the kind of leadership
that
built that national unity back up and um
you know when a country gets so far gone
it's it
you eventually get your leak on you or
your perhaps
napoleon um or you know any of the other
examples of somebody who just sort of
has to come back in and restore things
as a national unity leader
i think uh with a trump presidency and a
trump continuation
you get people building a communi a
community a communal identity
around the constitution around america
but uh if we carry on with the path that
was
you know everything before trump you get
you know
people are dejected disconnected there's
constant fighting over
you know identity-based issues and the
interest
of the elites is just to enrich
themselves as the ship crashes because
why bother if the ship's going down
someone was um referencing buchanan as
one of the worst u.s presidents ever and
it was the lead up to the civil war i
think james buchanan
um and that biden is kind of reminiscent
of a buchanan that he's going to be a
nobody know nothing president
four years of that's going to drive
people just to chaos and and what people
need to realize too is i bring this up a
lot is history is condensed
when we read it so it may be that we get
a four years of a buchanan like biden
and then it results in the return of
trump in 2024
and then maybe some kind of civil war or
maybe trump comes back and fixes it i
don't know
but uh when people read about the civil
war or any war any history
they read the highlights back to back to
back to back to back you know especially
if you read wikipedia it's like this
happened this happened this happened
people got to realize man there was like
months and years where nothing happened
and i think that's one reason why people
don't understand it could happen here
and we could be in it right now
because they expect one day to turn the
tv on and have a news anchor go like
anderson cooper says
ladies and gentlemen america is in a
civil war and that's like that's it
that's how we know no you you won't
you you really won't you know i think
what's interesting is uh was it seven
states seceded from the union before
there was a there was a war
and it was actually i don't know how
long it took after the secession before
the the fire you know
the shot at fort sumner before actually
kicked off and then other states seceded
so there's actually a time period where
they're like wow states have seceded
that's crazy huh
and then nothing happened but then there
was war obviously
rob ingram says tuned in late so i
missed everything hope your wrist is
okay homie
you among others are the reason i'm
moving towards starting my own podcast
on poop tube channel you guys rock your
friendly neighborhood philly personal
trainer appreciate it man
let's see sleepy dan says just add in
2016 when talking fraud then youtube was
okay with it
yeah uh let's see evgeny says why not
move out of the u.s to eastern europe or
other place which is not currently
aflames
you know i was actually looking at uh
ukraine for a while yeah because uh uh
but you don't have the second amendment
you know that's one thing that's very
unique to the united states where people
could actually defend themselves ukraine
though cost of living is very affordable
and you have a lot more freedom there
than you do in a lot of parts of western
europe if you're a middle class american
and you
are working remote and you can work out
of a place like ukraine you are a king
it's really it's really crazy so i think
it's like a hundred bucks a month for
rent
on average yeah well the the the the
uh the income for ukraine for ukrainians
is really really really low so as an
american it's like you go there you can
have whatever you want
the cost of living the people the
atmosphere just life overall is better
for a lot of expats
and i know a lot of expats but again i i
well you know because i
when i went there and i covered the euro
my dance stuff i made friends and i'm
like
so cool but i'm not ukrainian so you
know but i was looking at property
because i was like look out
like not to disrespect ukrainians but
it's like if you're a middle class
american you can get a really fancy pad
man it's like
cost of living wow crazy
an average reactor says i am a
right-leaning libertarian and i want to
be involved in journalism because i
developed a moral conviction to fight
against the establishment that betrays
us in broad daylight any advice on
entry-level options
you know these days i really don't know
yeah because i used to just go out and
cover stuff but now it's like people are
fighting each other it used to be so
easy you can't travel anymore you know
coveted lockdowns so i don't know what
you do
good luck i would i mean go to side
there's an organization called
leadership institute and they excel at
placing
prospective journalists into programs
and give them a little bit a little bit
of a subsidy to make it worthwhile and
put you into different publications so
i'd say look into that leadership
institute
also we were very lucky because we
started before the crackdown
now imagine starting brand new right all
these crackdowns that
prevent you from reaching a wider
audience so 10 years ago
it was still sort of easy like you had a
good message you you knew a little bit
of how to make videos you were golden
you were great
now you say something wrong about the
election you're done and you're
no one will overhear of you yeah shane
says i'm a union worker and my dad is a
union representative
i tried to explain to my dad how biden
is going to hurt us but he passes me as
crazy
because he bases his ideology off of
mainstream media and what our union
overarching authorities say
what do i say to him um
man that's tough you can say do you
depends on the union he's in but uh joe
biden is in favor of free trade
agreements which will likely result in
your dad losing his job so
it's very hard to convince family
members so it's always important not to
come at it at a combative way not to try
to force information down his or her
throat
it's always important to share
information that's important but come
at it from a perspective like hey i saw
this i don't know what to think of it
since you're so much older and wiser
what do you think of this
and that worked specifically well in my
on my family as well when it came to a
lot of important issues
the way persuasion works is you convince
somebody of something that they think
they
always and already believed and with in
those situations i would encourage you
to
to get at your dad the same way the
grand canyon was built
you find one little crack one little
thing that he clearly kind of disagrees
with biden on
and you kind of put some water in there
you freeze it and expand it yeah and
then it makes the crack bigger and you
put water and freeze it expand it again
and you keep
just find that one thing and use it to
open up a much
bigger well and before you know it you
know four years from now like
man that biden would it well so uh just
hit him
i can tell you one of the basics of
opinion manipulation
is uh it's called um rapport extreme in
turn
i don't know if you've ever heard of
this but it's a way you convince someone
to move their opinion oh first of all
i'll just go through this whole thing
um you can't make someone go from say
being
loving a person to hating a person
immediately you can only push
people within their reasonable
boundaries so if someone says this is my
friend they're cool
you can't make them say i hate this
person but you can make them say
yeah that is kind of annoying he does
that you do that enough times eventually
the person's going to be like
he is so annoying man it never stops you
get them to that point
so rapport extreme turn is basically the
first thing you have to do is agree with
them
so that they feel you know like oh this
is what we agree on you build a rapport
now there's a trusting relationship the
extreme is
you then present something that you like
about joe biden
that you know your dad can't agree with
the turn is then you acknowledge your
dad is right and that opinion was too
extreme and it was
him who convinced you so an example uh
what's what's the best example like okay
let's say war
joe biden was uh party obama
administration got us in more war he
never met a war he didn't like
yep so would you do it again the first
thing you would say is you'd be like you
know i was thinking about i think you're
right about joe biden
you know he's probably the better choice
for a lot of reasons and then your dad
you know or your friend or your family
member is going to be like oh yeah yeah
of course
they're like me now they're in my tribe
you then give them the extreme opinion
they can't accept i mean me personally
the reason i like him is because i mean
how many wars you know did he did he get
us involved in
that was a good thing and you don't want
to be crazy you just say something that
your dad's gonna be like i don't know
about that i think the wars were a
problem
you know that's the one thing i don't
like about it so it's similar to what
you're saying about finding the thing
and then your response is the turn all
right well
okay i guess you're right the wars
aren't a good thing but you know fine i
guess you're right
they've now given you an opinion against
biden and they've affirmed
you know you were wrong so it's it's
it's it's a it's an old-school uh it's
like a basic manipulation trick
she's very deceptive absolutely can you
do it in a more loving way like
i i like that biden has these things but
i don't like the war
here's the problem yeah i guess i see so
this is one of the reasons i stopped
working for nonprofits because i hate
doing these kinds of things but
the the issue is at fundraising you know
like raising money for you know how you
convince someone to give you money
oof it's tough and eventually once you
get good at it you understand
the system and how it works and how
you're playing this game the problem is
there are people who are naturally good
at doing things like this without
realizing it
and that's considered morally acceptable
you could just naturally
like poke someone and be like well i
think the wars are great then you know
you know and it works for you
but people who get really good at
working a long time eventually start to
understand what they're doing
and then you're like man i'm just just
pulling people's strings and
manipulating i don't like it
so then i don't want to be involved in
that you know i don't want to i don't
want to work a job where
the goal was to find a way to navigate
someone's mind
to convince them and you can you can
justify it any way you want but
i didn't think it was all that
entertaining you know
anyway we've gone a little bit over so i
think we'll we'll start to wrap things
up make sure you smash that like button
if you haven't already
is there anything you want to mention
your social media or promote anything or
let people know about what's going on
yeah there's longer-term solutions to
the stuff i'm working on and if you want
to stay tuned or get involved just
follow me on
i'm on twitter matt brainard i'm on gab
and parlor
so you can find me there um so just stay
in touch folks right on man thanks for
hanging out
thanks you can follow me on twitter
instagram parlor at tim cast
you can check out my other youtube
channels youtube.comtymcast and
youtube.comcastnews we do this show live
monday through friday at 8 pm
you can check us out on itunes spotify
give us a good review it really does
help with with the ranking and then
it gets more people to watch so also
share if you think the show is good and
word of mouth really helps
um you can also check out the other
people who are hanging out here we have
luke caskey
yes i am on youtube.com forward slash we
are change and you can find me on
twitter instagram
facebook under luke we are change and
tim thank you so much for having me on i
know i am not mainstream media friendly
youtube loves mainstream media but i
appreciate you taking the risk
they don't like you but what have you
said that's been all that like you know
crazy
nothing and i never and i never really
did i know i've always you know
i like thinking i like outside the box
kind of research
and uh yeah i mean well maybe they'll
ban me and they'll be like you had luke
on too much
could happen we also got ian he's
hanging out hi um
and then you know luke's so humble he's
got merchandise up the waz
i just want to give a shout out where
where can they get that thank you so
much
ian teesprings.com forward slash stores
forward slash we are change
thank you ian matt can people still
donate to your organization
well we're not asking for donations i
know it's a rare thing for somebody to
say but um
just follow me on stockmed we have more
projects coming up
if someone were to donate to your
charity how would they go about doing
that
um i would say go to givesengo.com
voter integrity and uh any money that's
left over at the end will go to a
permanent
uh patriotic voter registration effort
and
anti-voter fraud effort cool thanks
thank you you can follow me to ian
crossland
right on and of course you can follow at
sourpatch lids who's pressing all the
buttons you can i'm pushing buttons like
a mad woman over here
my friends tomorrow is probably gonna be
the biggest show we've ever had we're
going to get in trouble
it could precipitate the uh the end
but it's going to be one of the it's
going to be fun and um
i don't want to call it revenge you know
but it's going to be a whole lot of fun
so i hope you're ready to come back
tomorrow at 8pm
and i'm sure most people have already
figured out what that means but i'll
leave it there thanks for hanging out
we'll see you all next time
you